they got them ladies and gentlemen the
individual who leaked the papers from
the Pentagon about what was going on in
Ukraine and there's some really
interesting details now now that it's
confirmed that this is just apparently
some 21 year old dude who was anti-war
and was trying to impress his friends it
basically confirms that what's in these
papers is real and what does that mean
it's all in all likelihood Russia is
actually winning and the U.S does have
Personnel on the ground that's right U.S
Special Forces confirmed on the ground
in Ukraine well how about that but not
just the U.S a whole bunch of other
countries too so we're gonna have to
jump into that one and uh oh boy U.S on
the ground do you think Russia looks at
what's happening there and says we're
not at war with the West when the West
actually has Intelligence and tactical
support working in that country in their
war against Russia that'll be fun and
then we'll talk about this video that's
that's come out showing one of the
Tennessee Democrats attacking motorists
in their cars with a street cone my
favorite part of this video is actually
one of the leftists Waddles around and
then Falls over acting like they got
struck by a vehicle and then flail and
flip around on the ground it's just
remarkable that we as a society take
these people seriously you know
everybody knows when you watch a soccer
match that dude didn't get hurt he's
rolling around the ground screaming
because like a feather touched his ankle
that's what these people do all the time
they'll be standing in the middle of the
street they'll hit a car themselves and
then flip onto their backs and start
screaming and for some reason
everybody's supposed to take that
seriously enough it's time to arrest
these people I guess the problem is the
cops are either unwilling or incapable
so we'll talk about that but before we
get started my friends head over to
we're first going to jump to cast brew
coffee casprewcoffee.com and you can
purchase your rise with Roberto Jr
breakfast blend this is our new coffee
company we launched it we're sponsoring
ourselves and your coffee if you order
today it's a pre-order and it will ship
by May 5th so recently entered
production definitely if you want to
support us you can go to casper.com and
also don't forget to head over to to
timcast.com click that join us button
become a member and you'll get access to
the members only uncensored show we have
those Monday through Thursday at about
10 10 p.m live on the front page of the
website and you'll also get access to
our Discord server where you can hang
out with like-minded individuals and if
you've been a member for at least six
months or you sign up at the 25 level
you can actually submit questions to
call into the show and talk to us and
our guests so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and so much more is
Winston Marshall
hi hi fellas thanks for having me on
your show Absolutely who are you what do
you do uh I'm a musician I was a
co-founding member of the band Mumford
and Sons and quit in 2021
over issues of free speech I'd say
fundamentally I had tweeted about a book
written by Andy no documenting antifa
and it caused some uh backlash you could
say it became a big story and initially
I apologized I'd say under under
quite some duress but also not perhaps
being open to not knowing the whole
situation and but that didn't rest for
my conscience and So eventually decided
the only thing I could do was
retract the apology and quit the band
and since doing that it's been coming up
to two years now I've launched a new
podcast with The Spectator which is a
British political magazine actually the
oldest political magazine in the world
and uh still making music and doing
media and writing and having fun so uh
but thanks for having me on your on your
show and uh I look forward to speaking
to you absolutely we also got Bill
ottman he's back hey guys thanks for
having me back yeah and Winston's also
performing this weekend at mines Fest at
the Vulcan your new record sector or
something I'm gonna play some old songs
some old songs yeah yeah but uh thank
you so much excited um uh Bill kindly
invited me to play the speak at the
Beacon uh where I met some of you guys
last um uh when was it ever last summer
June or something yeah and uh very
exciting what you're doing with mines I
look forward to hearing more about the
uh the latest yeah and yeah we're all in
Austin it's great to be here with you
guys
um Tim's got his sold out show tomorrow
night yeah and Tim cast IRL live at the
Vulcan tomorrow in Austin Texas yeah so
if anyone there's there's a few tickets
left almost sold out mine's Fest but you
can get them at the at the Vulcan site
or at festival.minds.com yeah we're
mine's is a free open source
decentralized social network working on
internet Freedom if anyone wants to
check it out minds.com right on Ian's
chilling oh I sure am man and Bill
you're just on Joe Rogan's podcast that
one I just saw the first hour of it on
Spotify today and man it is nice to hear
you talking about agpl3 with Joe Rogan
we went deep brother nice job Joe AI
aliens what's better it gets deeper I'm
gonna watch the other two hours later
Winston always a pleasure man I met you
last year too at the at the science Fest
so here's to many more I'll see you on
Saturday and then of course Luke and
Caskey if we are changed aliens has my
attention and also before we start
friends don't let friends eat seed oils
that's why I'm wearing the shirt that
I'm wearing right now which you could
get on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and today's
Meetup was a huge success it was 3 30 on
a Thursday and like 50 people came out
Ian was my special guest Ian thank you
so much for coming out I'm going to be
doing another our members only meet up
in Miami in a few days all on Luke
unfiltered.com Ian the crowd was awesome
we talked about magnetism we talked
about crazy technology anti-gravity it
was wild interesting crowd thanks for
having a conversation thank you so much
that was awesome
and of course sir just press on the
buttons what up sir yes I am what's up
y'all all right everyone so let's we'll
jump into this first story
we got big news ladies and gentlemen
from Business Insider Jack tahera 21
arrested in connection with the Pentagon
document leak attorney general Merrick
Garland the suspected Pentagon leaker
was arrested Tuesday by federal agents
in Dighton Massachusetts Merrick Garland
identified the suspect as Jack tahera 21
a Guardsman specializing in intelligence
tahera allegedly shared highly
classified documents about the Ukraine
war online
so they're treating this guy like you
know Enemy Number One Public Enemy
Number One but uh there's there's a few
important things just to bring up right
away as to why the story matters one the
mainstream media lied to Joe Biden lied
three it seems like Russia is actively
winning the war and four actually there
are U.S Special Forces on the ground
this is now confirmed it's not
speculation and uh well you know
everything you thought about the war
you've been lied to about and I can just
assume that anybody listening to the
show is not surprised at all because I
don't know been here done that yeah I
mean they've been on the ground since
2014 and this latest action by the
Federal Bureau of Investigations and the
doj going after this whistleblower
treating him like a terrorist by the way
the way that they captured him just just
is just absolutely crazy when this guy
is coming forward providing documents
that by the way the corporate media was
gaslighting us telling us we're real oh
the these files don't exist and they
said oh no they do exist but this one
portion about the number of Ukrainian
dead troops is definitely manipulated
here out of all those documents and then
they told us oh it was definitely the
Russians that released this information
and today we found out that exactly was
not true at all and there's a lot of big
things in these documents they were out
on Discord for a number of weeks no one
really paid attention to them but now
after all the gaslighting after all the
propaganda all the lies that looks like
these documents are legit and they do
speak to a lot of the bigger things that
are happening in Ukraine that we should
have a real serious conversation about
Sir Ian they cut you off oh Senator Joe
manchin tweeted out I don't know if you
guys saw this eight hours ago in my
lifetime I've never seen the United
States of America in a more just war and
that's a video and people are like
Congress didn't declare war bro like
this guy's a senator and he's Virginia
that's that's really concerned yeah
we're going to make sure he's not a
senator for much longer granted he's got
a few more years left and something we
can do about that because you can't
recall Senators but that guy's a scumbag
yeah I mean we used to respect Daniel
Ellsberg and the Pentagon papers and
muckrakers and whistleblowers in this
country and now we're doing the exact
opposite of that with the Washington
Post and New York Times being accused
here working with bellincott
specifically hunting down this
whistleblower just a few days ago six
days ago Reuters was saying that
according to Anonymous U.S officials
ever heard that one before you hear it
all the time when they try to tell you a
bunch of Lies according to U.S Anonymous
officials Russia was behind this leak
again why are they continuing to lie why
do we believe them the only real way
that we could get truth in this country
is through whistleblowers so for them to
go after this guy so hard really shows
you how they're trying to hide the
bigger truths here because you know if
people really knew what the government
was doing if if everything was
Declassified they would be pissed people
know that and that's why they try to
suppress the story as much as they did
that's true too but the big thing here
is that in the documents the reason the
media comes out and says these documents
appear to be real but may have been
manipulated that is to say that someone
took real documents and altered the
numbers the reason why they had to lie
is that the documents show that Russia
has only suffered around 17
000 casualties
despite the fact the media has been
reporting 200 000 and that Ukraine has
suffered around seventy thousand which
is now that we know who this guy is now
that we see that it's just some dude who
got arrested not a Russian uh oh looks
like Russia's winning the war in Ukraine
we also have dumping more and more money
into it and and we are losing not that I
want to be over there and we have Kirby
coming out telling the Press not to
cover it who's Kirby uh John Kirby he's
like a spokesperson
I mean just a shocking National Security
spokesperson yeah that's the guy you're
you're talking about here specifically
coming out yeah don't report on this and
again the Pentagon also said don't do it
yeah yeah Pentagon also sent notices to
social media companies saying don't do
this Elon Musk commented on this saying
you know if there's one way uh not to
bring attention to a story this is not
the way to do it I'm paraphrasing he
didn't say it in the exact way but but
this is this is a big story and
highlights a lot of Ukrainian young men
that are dying that are passing away and
I think we have to start asking the
question why what is the goal here what
is the purpose here what's really going
on here why are we being told
everything's peachy everything's the
Russians are going to be defeated any
moment now you hear it on the television
all the time history repeats Russia
usually has a very bad way of starting
Wars but the longer the wars continue
historically the Russians have a huge
amount of Manpower and they throw into
these wars and usually are more
successful and are able to defeat their
victories the longer a war goes on so so
to to one prolong this conflict in the
history in the Afghanistan of Europe
that is Ukraine is absolutely crazy in
in the first way even if you are a
pro-ukraine but second of all how many
innocent young men you're you're
destroying entire population of young
men that are being butchered and
slaughtered for what the prophet of of
the military industrial complex I used
to think that but uh you guys know about
that that royal family that got all
inbred I think they're called the
Habsburg yeah that was that it the
Habsburg you mean the the British royal
family is that them no it's like a
European royal family and they're all
inbred and the Habsburg family was it
the Habsburg family most royal families
well no for sure for sure but uh it got
me thinking as you're talking about this
like why are we overseas and you know I
thought about 1913 you know the start of
the Federal Reserve some authoritarian
strong-minded individuals are you know
meeting on Jekyll Island and they're
like we're going to create a centralized
banking system
and then you know they have kids who
have kids who have kids and then you had
you know Dr Ron Paul in the show just
come right out and say that there was a
revolution when the government murdered
its President John F Kennedy and it's
like well okay then and I'm just
thinking about it and I'm like that's
like the kid of the Federal Reserve
people and now what we're dealing with
is like the Habsburg Offspring which is
our current military industrial complex
like they're two inbred and deformed to
properly function in terms of
international policy so while China is
basically taking over while they're
doing negotiations with Saudi Arabia and
Brazil to get off the US dollar
our habsburg-esque military industrial
complexes like we must conquer Ukraine
and you're like for what dude it is the
habsburgs they're known for the
distinctive Habsburg jaw it's h-a-b-s
and they were it's like
like if you look at pictures of the
Habsburg jaw you'll see they were like
for being inbred but these people aren't
inbred I think they know what they're
doing because they always do it and and
when it comes to losing when it comes to
Human Sacrifice these people don't care
if the United States loses these people
don't care if Ukraine loses Ukraine has
been used by many corrupted politicians
by many internationalists by many
globalists there's a reason BlackRock
and Goldman Sachs has all the contracts
right now in Ukraine there's there's a
reason they don't care look what
happened in Libya look what happened in
Afghanistan look what happened in Iraq
these wars aren't meant to be won we
have to think from the perspective of
these people don't care about you they
don't care about the United States they
don't care about how we look to the rest
of the world they care about their
contracts they care about their money
they care about their blood sacrifice
which essentially they're doing here
when we could have had peace we could
have had negotiations we could have had
this conflict ended last year in April
but no the Western leaders got involved
flew into Ukraine and specifically made
sure that this conflict was prolonged
which is absolutely insane which just
absolutely crazy and now there's U.S
Special Forces operating inside of
Ukraine with Mission critical functions
14 U.S troops what are they doing
exactly there we don't know 50 UK
Special Forces 15 French Special Forces
and 17 lot fee and Special Forces over
100 U.S Personnel in Ukraine right now
and uh how many about 100 U.S Personnel
in Ukraine right now those are the
estimates according to these documents
that came out there and uh even you know
Donald Trump came out and said during
the Syrian War he killed a whole bunch
of Russians because the Russians were
fighting there how many troops are we
losing are we even going to be
documenting how many U.S forces or U.S
soldiers I mean there's people who
volunteer there but officially this
changes the game as well Trump also you
know responded to Tucker essentially
acknowledging that Nordstrom was
perpetrated by us he said it in a in a
kind of he alluded to it in a very
sneaky way he said it he was like I
don't want to make us look Tucker asked
him who who blew up the pipeline he's
like well I don't to make our side look
back but it definitely wasn't the
Russians uh but again Trump's also
analysis of Putin and Zi and Kim uh was
also uh pretty interesting that
interview was also the Dynamics between
Tucker and Trump that's also something
people are really looking into as well
that are that was really eye-opening but
what does any of this have to do with my
beer
that's a good point Tim what does it it
might get a little more expensive maybe
it'll get cheaper who's to say no we had
Jesse Kelly on the show the other day
and he was mentioning that Bud Light
this story was the first time his
neighbors actually asked him about
politics and and the reason I bring that
up is I'm just like okay so basically us
has Personnel on the ground we are
actively at war with Russia without a
declaration from Congress we've dumped a
hundred plus billion dollars into this
Russia wants to send nuclear weapons to
Belarus China is getting Brazil and
other countries off the U.S dollar and
uh well the U.S Empire is all coming
crashing down or whatever it is you want
to call it and the only thing that
animates people is
otherwise what I think about this
transparency concept we talk a lot about
transparency it's a big part of minds
and why the code is free and open source
is because you know this guy Jack that
this 21 year old that is arrested for
for leaking the documents you actually
talked about with Joe Rogan on on his
show this was before his name came out
and it's like you posed a question like
if every piece of data was released
would it even be a good thing like it
could very well just cause massive war
so
I don't know if it's always good to leak
every doc you know no not every document
but we need vastly more transparency
than we have I'm curious how how
specific did he go through any kind of
like a legitimate whistleblower process
for this no just put them on Discord he
put them on this so that's that that's
kind of asking for back yeah there's no
such thing as a legitimate whistleblower
process well I mean there there there's
there is and there is and then and then
they get ignored or shut down or told to
shut up just like William Benny has fair
enough no no I'm not saying that he
should have like gone and asked
permission I'm saying that if you you
know in terms of redacting names and you
know in certain circumstances there
there is like a due diligence process
that can make sense to be a little bit
careful yes I understand what you're
saying I I feel like all of these
platitudes are just Comforts for those
who want the rules for themselves that
is to say if the United States does
something like Barack Obama blows up a
kid who's gonna hold them accountable
they get away with it but if any other
country does it oh you better believe
they're going to come out and cite all
of the rules and read every single one
of them so when I when I when I think of
whistleblowers they say well he should
have gone through the process right the
process by which he goes to a commanding
officer and says they're lying about
this and this needs to go to the public
and they say thank you for bringing us
to our attention have a nice day the the
process and the rules are intended to
stop people from telling the American
people what's actually going on and how
they're lying cheating and stealing and
destroying our country it also tells the
world but I mean go ahead oh I mean all
the Russian people know now too that's
part of it they knew though they knew
though you think in Russia they really
believed 200 000 soldiers had been
killed they lived there but I don't
think they knew that there were 100
American
Russians actually came out with a very
interesting statement when these
documents first came out calling it a
psyop so the Russians and the Russian I
believe Ministry of Defense a couple
days ago as soon as these documents came
out said we don't believe them we think
that they're they're being deployed as a
way of tricking us so that was their
initial response to all of this
officially by by the Russian government
but but also a lot of other things came
out from these documents including how
the United States wasn't just
infiltrating and spying on the Russian
government and the Russian military but
also the South Korean military the
Israeli uh military and the Israeli
government as well and there was a lot
of techniques some people argue have
been disclosed here I don't know I
haven't seen that personally myself but
that's the argument we're seeing against
some of these leaks being released that
the number of spies the number and
techniques of how they infiltrated these
institutions was also leaked I haven't
seen that yet but that's some of the
talking points that I'm seeing out there
this this could be a psyop it it's worth
pointing out that he's only 21 years old
I mean as whistleblowers come Snowden
was young and he was what 29.
that he this guy Jack would know that
he's going to get done on the Espionage
Act he's thrown his life away and he's a
kid yeah that is that not a tall suspect
how young he is like is that what what's
perhaps or maybe not young and a
reckless certainly Reckless yeah I
wonder if there is a psyop because think
about how perfect it would be if you
want to get misinformation oh no oh no a
leaked document and then it might like
basically what happens is when they when
the media said some of the information
may be altered may be altered by the
United States so that when it goes out
it's a psyop to manipulate and confuse
the other countries that are involved in
this but but it is interesting to see
the corporate media's response here
because when Donald Trump was President
of the United States when there was
leakers within his administration they
were cheered they were celebrated they
were promoted their story many times was
just reported without even question a
verification sometimes but now we have a
leaker and then the Washington Post and
the New York Times track it down with
Bella cat track them down and hunt them
down that that's a big component of the
story that people have been pointing out
that the mainstream media basically
acted like in in like an intelligence
operation extension of the state yep for
the state that is when the government
was like hey who leaked this all of the
news outlets said we're gonna hunt this
person down and figure out who it is but
when it came to Donald Trump's leakers
they were like we must protect
whistleblowers that's the game being
played today man yeah I mean we need
sweeping whistleblower protection reform
I think that that that's a a new type of
legislation that just needs more Focus
that's what we got with uh the arrow
program which is the all domain anomaly
research office for UFO whistleblowers
so now in the ndaa there's there's now
specific protection they're doing an
audit of the whole government for for
UFO related information but the reason
people weren't coming forward before is
because they were they're terrified of
coming forward what was that thing you
guys were talking about who's talking
about this that uh Tucker Carlson said
that whenever troops go like meet Aliens
or whatever their brains melt or
something like Tucker Carlson was on the
full send podcast and he described a
situation where he was looking into a
story where he was hearing of a bunch of
U.S personnel and U.S soldiers that had
interactions with aliens that had
essentially their brains scrambled
um so so again I'm paraphrasing here
from listening to Tucker Carlson Tucker
Carlson explains it a little bit better
but essentially describing how he has
made contact within people who have
verified that there are other entities
out there and when they do get near
human beings they essentially destroy
their mind I would guess that it's more
like that Cuban thing remember they were
doing that like noise weapon or low
frequency Vanna syndrome yes that's
aliens I think it's human I think it's
human technology and they're just
putting chimeric animals if they or or
you know if they think they saw
something that's not human they might be
right but it could be like part human
you mean the people who think they saw
aliens yeah if they show them if they're
gonna show somebody something and try
and give them a red herring they may be
doing like genetic work on it on animals
and be like look it's from another
planet and then in the background
they've got like vorpal sound just
messing with your DNA and the people I
don't know about all that but I will say
I think if you believe the US Military
and U.S government is not doing genetic
experimentation it hasn't been for the
past hundred years you are a crazy
person that you guys ever hear of the
humanzy
the story is that uh the Russians here's
here's the crazy thing about the story
chimps so so you can't just hybridize
two like species willy-nilly you have to
actually figure out which which species
has to be the female and which has to be
the male
and I'll tell you the horrifying part
about it
human babies are big chimp babies are
small
chimps have smaller bodies humans have
bigger bodies so when they were doing
these experiments the urban legend tells
that you can't take male parts and put
it into a female chimp because the
female chimp is too small you got to put
the male chimp stuff in the human female
and the human female has to carry the
chimp human hybrid so urban legend is
the Soviets actually
forcefully took women women and made
them do this now I know about all that
maybe my point is this
yes the U.S government the Chinese
government they're all doing this stuff
and there was a big story a couple years
ago China is trying to make super
soldiers they are doing human genetic
modification to make
was it Uber mentioned is that what it is
like super superhuman Superman yeah
Superman yup that was the Nazi plan I
think was the Ubermensch yep so I I look
if you know I don't know whatever it is
you're talking about because we're
talking about aliens we're talking about
I don't know where all this came
scrambling the brains with vibration
like Havana I'm into it we're in a race
car just just turning the uh you made me
think of the heart attack the CIA heart
attack gun which we know exists that
that came out in the 70s in the church
church yeah so now let me tell us what
they have now right exactly whenever
ever I hear anything about alien
anything I am I immediately think it's
human how could this be human technology
there's there's so zero to no evidence
very little evidence of any
uh animal come from another planet
there's none you know my favorite thing
about UFO stories is they tend to take
place near U.S military bases and
experimental research facilities so
there's like one story that was in the
press and this one is blew my mind the
story made it the press it was like
Naval pilot tells story of strange
objects he sees in the sky and then it's
like in the in 2013 he was flying a
routine Mission he brought the report to
his supervisors who said this is nothing
and ignore it and he was shocked what if
this was the Russians what if it was the
Chinese how could they ignore this
report and I was just like uh-huh maybe
it's because they know what it is and
you don't so shut your mouth and then
the best part was the the sighting was
100 miles out from a U.S experimental
aircraft facility and I'm like so
basically due to with limited clearance
is doing a routine exercise and see some
experimental aircraft reports it to his
super commanding officer who's like yeah
don't worry about it and then it's like
they're covering up aliens and it's like
bro that's our base those are our
weapons shut up yeah they have a
technology called super cavitation and
what they do is they mount lasers on the
front of an aircraft and then force them
into each other and shoot this area in
front of the aircraft causing space time
to cavitate and create a vacuum in front
of the plane which draws the plane
forward and causes it not to create a
sonic boom it still makes noise but it
doesn't make Is that real yeah super
capitation what uh this is according to
Jeremy riss who was on Brett Weinstein's
podcast talking about it so there's
technology like that if you see real
craft that sounds like warp drive it's
it's definitely a start towards that
because if you can evacuate space in
front of you you'll be pulled forward
that's a big part of moving through
space well I mean this would that would
only work in an atmosphere this is
mostly the density right you said
warping space time uh right you're right
you're talking about creating a vacuum
in front of you which causes its warping
pressure thank you for correcting that
it's warping the atmosphere they may
have technology that works based on I
don't know
um and then there's also the idea of
talking plasma which is where they focus
lasers from a distance and they
coordinate them and where they
triangulate it creates like a a ball of
plasma that they can move around really
fast like a laser pointer and they're
probably doing it from space stations
right it's basically just a
three-dimensional laser pointer and we
Chase it around like a cat and so
there's both and it'll confuse people if
they think they're the same thing
they're going to be very confused
because there probably are actual craft
that are able to move
it to be pulled along how did we start
talking about aliens and stuff uh did
Billy you bring it up I probably you
brought him the arrow were you were you
talking with Rogan about it or something
yeah well we were talking about the the
arrow program which is like a
well-funded government program for
researching this now
um and then we also went deep into the
Virginia Brazil incident but I don't
know how deep you guys want to go
where's the incident there's a amazing
documentary that came out earlier this
year called moment of contact by James
Fox
um who and it's basically Virginia and
Brazil is basically the Roswell of
Brazil so you know you go there and it's
like huge UFOs it's like Virginia
Virginia
I was like wait for Virginia yeah
Virginia it's similar yeah it's weird
um but hundreds of people throughout the
city uh saw objects actually these girls
saw beings apparently and the whole wing
of the hospital had to get demolished
because the smell from this thing
apparently was so bad it infected the
whole building and this is not like the
mayor of the city currently
is took James Fox like all through the
city the mayor of Virginia is like
totally all in on it they have multiple
women when did it happen it happened in
96. wow so there's a lot of
documentation and it is it's either the
biggest
UFO story in history or the greatest
hoax of all time but like the the sheer
number of people who saw the military
checkpoints all over this like you guys
got to watch the documentary I'm not
like let's do it let's let's go deep
next time after you've all seen it
because it is completely wild I I was I
suppose so so bringing it back I guess
if the question was the US real the US
really does have this crazy advanced
technology why aren't they using it in
Ukraine why aren't they using it in
general well it's if we have it it
doesn't necessarily mean that we know
how to use it if there's any kind of
recovered materials no I mean like the
US is developing weapons and stuff
because these wars aren't meant to be
won they're meant to be prolonged and
and when you continue the war you of
course have so much of not only profit
incentive but control incentive you have
to understand the the Ukrainian uh
country also controls a lot of the wheat
that's exported all around the world
Russia also when it's being hit with its
sanctions specifically controls a lot of
energy around the world as well so
limiting the amount of energy limiting
the amount of food around the globe is
something that a lot of these top
globalists are really into and and love
having that kind of position of power uh
and and essentially I don't think they
care if if Ukraine wins or loses at the
end of the day especially with how
they're treating them especially with
how they're prolonging this battle now
there's a bunch of black projects
there's a bunch of black budgets there's
a reason trillions and trillions of
dollars usually goes missing from the
Pentagon every few so years what are
they spending that money on well
probably more ways of destroying the
world but they also know at the same
time we use this latest kind of insane
technological advancement the Russians
will probably use something as well or
the Chinese will use something as well
and they're also developing a lot of
this kind of Doomsday style technology I
mean the Russians are openly talking
about a Poseidon nuclear bomb that will
send a tsunami of nuclear waste towards
uh what they say they have it the
Russians say they have a lot of stuff
doesn't mean they always do they kind of
also talked about how great their latest
tanks were and we really haven't seen
them kind of highlight that in the
battlefield that's happening in Ukraine
so again a lot of this is also saber
rattling a lot of this is also just kind
of posturing so when we look at this
larger perspective and picture
um it is a very complex one but but when
you really look at it yes there is
technology that could kill us whether
it's artificial intelligence whether
it's tsunamis whether it's nuclear bombs
nuclear bomb are still just archaic old
decades uh very very ancient weapons
compared to the latest technological
advancement that they have now what
exactly do we have what do they have who
the hell knows but it's scary and it's
terrible but never doing all this
including when we look at the realm of
bioweapons that could be used here and
genetically specific weapons that could
be used here especially with so many
governments harvesting people's uh
genetic codes and DNA code have you guys
seen the uh the video of the ship with
the laser on it they point they point
the laser at the Drone and the Drone
burst into flames is it like an
invisible laser it's like a microwave or
something infrared I'm pretty sure so uh
not microwave I don't think that's
that's a laser uh it's infrared so it's
this gigantic lens and it just points at
the Drone and the Drone just bursts into
flames then crashes that's how you beat
drone swarms what kind of are humans
what kind of range can it I think it was
like thousands of feet or something
ridiculous it was nuts and I'm just
wondering if they have that kind of
stuff like they don't use it on people
like imagine if they set that up around
Ukraine they built the these big towers
I guess the issue is electricity if the
power is being cut yeah because if you
have a power source like fusion
generator in addition to that you don't
want to end the war the
military-industrial complex maybe wants
to prolong the war you don't want to
lose your most advanced piece of
technology to the enemy just in case if
you have like one or two Fusion powered
high beam Weaponry you don't want to put
it in Ukraine because if someone gets a
hold of that I don't think it's as
simple as you know the we don't want to
win the war I think that there are major
factions of the military industrial
complex contractors and whatnot who have
like a ton of financial interest in the
war but you know a lot of people in the
military I think do want to so there's
it's not black and white like like
I want to ask you guys did you guys hear
about that uh that that cow Farm or
whatever that blew up what was it 18 000
cows how much how many it was like they
burned to death or something well yeah
where's that so I don't know did you
guys do you guys know where it was
someone looking to look it up because I
don't have the story pulled up but we
just started talking about you know war
and collapse and all that stuff and then
what I'm seeing from a lot of
commentators I'm seeing from a lot of
older people that are saying like all of
my life I have never seen this many food
plants and you know Farms blow up burn
down or otherwise just be destroyed that
was in Texas actually it was in Texas
people and and I'm seeing people be like
it feels like something else is going on
here and we're talking about Ukraine
Ukraine is the Bread Basket of Europe I
gotta wonder how much of this may be
intentional intentionally disrupting and
taking out food supplies
like what are the chances I'm not saying
it's true I'm saying what are the
chances that powerful Global Elites fear
climate change to the point that they
would actively destroy food plants farms
and Ukraine the breadbasket of Europe
for the purpose of reducing food supply
and limiting population growth again not
saying that's true I'm saying like all
of these things seem to be happening so
I'll put it this way whether or not
there's any Grand conspiracy there
because I don't see any evidence for
that I'm just saying that food plants
are being shut down through fires cows
are burning to death chicken farms all
of that stuff and then you've got the
Ukrainian War you've got the it was a
Dutch Farmers being told to stop farming
all of those things happening at once
and I'm like whether it's on purpose or
otherwise food production is shutting
down I think one of the phenomenons at
play there with those sort of Elites
isn't necessarily like you I haven't
seen evidence of it although I've read
most of of cloud Schwab's books and what
there is evidence is is that there has a
completely different set of priorities
and if your priority is to defeat this
great a supposed climate apocalypse you
just forget about the other things so I
think that's maybe more more at play and
that's certainly the case in the
Netherlands with the the Dutch farmer
revolts where they just prioritize their
green policy completely neglecting the
uh the farmers themselves and and that's
why they they stormed up against yeah
and there's an exam in California with
them shutting down gas powered cars
they're say like by 2035 they're not
going to sell gas fire cars but then
they say hey we're having a we're having
a heat wave don't charge your electric
car please uh the short-sightedness and
heavy-handedness of motion with
government sometimes it I agree with you
what's your church
I think it's done on purpose to be
honest with you sorry Bill you're well I
was just it's interesting that you
actually read class Schwab's books I
want to hear a little bit more about
that like what is his what's your
feeling from him the most terrifying
thing and and if there's one book to
read it's uh it's the it's not the great
reset it's the great narrative because
in this book
he tries to create what is essentially a
new quasi-religion with a new moral
structure in fact there's even a chapter
called morals and values where they into
they they replace the metaphysic that
normal religions have let's say with a
god with climate catastrophe and I mean
the all of his literature is a total
joke you know he keeps saying I don't
want to catastrophize but throughout all
of it it is like climate catastrophe
climate catastrophe climate catastrophe
so and that's the new God he's trying to
create and he's trying to build a moral
structure on top of that and that's how
he's trying to unite the world instead
of essentially it sounds like
the perspective is correct me if I'm
wrong there is no climate crisis and
he's creating a unifying enemy to try
and create a moral structure around for
the sake of globalism I think he thinks
there is a climate crisis I think he
believes the if you read the um the UN
reports on on the climate and and the
the the he takes the worst scenarios uh
they're usually written as unlikely or
highly unlikely but he'll take the worst
case scenarios and think we need to do
something about this so I I'm not sure
how
a good as far as you can have good faith
with right a good faith scenario is that
he really believes that well this he'll
do anything to guys this this has me
scared we gotta help Obama we've got to
help him he he must not know this he
bought a waterfront property in Martha's
Vineyard someone's got to send send him
an email as he texted me earlier
Billy boobs Gates also beachfront
property oh no do they know I don't know
we gotta help him well the thing is let
him know that the water levels are gonna
run there could be a climate catastrophe
if we do nothing but the problem with
these models is they don't take into
account mitigating factors changes in
technology a little carbon capture I got
an answer for you guys in all
seriousness when everyone says if there
really was a climate catastrophe why
would Bill Gates and Barack Obama and
many others buy waterfront property and
my my answer is it's simple because you
will own nothing and you will be happy
their plan is I can own this waterfront
property because we're going to solve
the problem by taking away everything
from you yeah we're gonna solve it by
and I justify it because I'm buying the
carbon credits I Can Fly they're
identifying everything they don't need
to justify anything if if let's say it's
this it let's say this it is a fact
ocean levels will rise if we do nothing
Barack Obama and Bill Gates are like oh
but we are going to do something we're
going to take away the property rights
of the regular working people
that will solve the ocean level crisis
and I can buy my property but how will
that solve the crisis if humans stop
consuming and stop producing and stop
reproducing and have all their property
taken away the mentality is this will
avert the climate crisis meaning the
powerful Elites are allowed to keep
their property keep their Jets keep
their cars so it's not that Obama
doesn't believe it's happening he just
believes he's going to win or or he
doesn't actually believe that there is a
climate catastrophe in the same way that
they all take private jets to get to
Davos if they truly believed it they
wouldn't take the Privacy this might be
the same same phenomenon they don't
actually I believe I don't this is my
point
I think it's possible they do believe it
and it's simply it's simple enough that
they're saying okay if we all keep
flying on private jets it's bad for the
environment so let's take away the
property rights of the poor people so we
don't have to stop get it John I get it
but sir no I was just saying John Kerry
actually recently got confronted what
you know how do you justify flying
private so often and he just point blank
said like I buy the carbon credits to
offset it and he thought that it was all
good the carbon credit's a total scam as
well if you'd like dig into that stuff
it's it almost impossible to guarantee
the carbon credits they've got to let
let's say You're Building trees you've
got to find a country that's politically
stable that the trees can last 30 40 50
is actually grow if you dig into that
stuff it's a total Con well so I want to
ask you because you know you're reading
Cloud Schwab's book is this a new
phenomenon or like did something happen
to wake you up because I'm just
imagining you're hanging out with your
band and they're you know writing a song
and then just over beers you're like
have you guys read this Klaus Schwab
stuff and they're like Winston what are
you talking about I I've been concerned
about uh uh Davos and the WF for a long
time I'd say a basically a analogy to to
elitist certainly in elitists unelected
ungerable types they I I've had that and
my family and you know I've journalists
and family and this is the kind of
conversations we have so I've been
interested in that stuff a long time and
I think just like seems like you you
fellas you see the stuff they say like
you'll be you'll earn nothing you'll be
happy and you think Bloody how what the
hell is this and why on Earth are my
elected officials why is my prime
minister going to Davos why is it it's
almost likely that the the labor party
will be in power in Britain and uh so
Kirsten who's later leader of the labor
party he was off at Davos why are these
people all going and in the conversation
with these unelected Elites like Cloud
Schwab who you can't get rid of who are
dictating the conversation why are they
going there
it's the Coachella politics it's exactly
like that you know it would be cool
though if like at Davos in their highly
secured facility is this machine called
the progenitor device that connects to
base reality outside the simulation
where all the world leaders communicate
with the 17 year old who's playing Sim
Earth
that's just that's just it you know
nothing nothing there's no big
conspiracy well the occult is a big part
of people that get really really rich
and they have no not much more to gain
they start going inward uh maybe Luke
you can explain more about that I know I
I've seen stuff I've read stuff I don't
know for sure Luke is Bohemian Grove
still happening uh yes so so is the
Bilderberg meeting but the Bilderberg is
not nearly as occult as but hold on hold
on we know of I gotta say this remember
that Bilderberg was a conspiracy theory
yeah this is the first they first first
told us it doesn't exist and if you
think it does exist you're a crazy
conspiracy theorist then they said oh it
does exist but nothing really happens
there it's just the world's most
powerful people coming together in
secret meeting together and having off
the Record meetings as they arrest
members of the press like myself trying
to report on it nothing to see there and
then they're like oh yeah little tidbits
here from The New York Times The
Washington Post admitting that this is
where politicians are selected to be
vice president this is where major
decisions are being met uh made
specifically with the larger
geopolitical effective at Bilderberg
last year there was a NATO member that
that was able to of course achieve NATO
member status that was first discussed
at this Bilderberg meeting I'm going to
look at the particular details of that
and get back to you guys here in a
little bit but as you were saying bill
it's not that they're playing politics
politics is just theater to them they're
playing a whole different game a whole
different perspective here and what you
guys are joking about is the actual
serious things that they're discussing
gives lectures about how there's going
to be useless human beings out there and
how we need to pacify them by giving
them drugs and video games and when we
look at what's happening when we look at
what's happening in society well yes
he's wrong he's absolutely he's
absolutely wrong but because they're the
ones building the the technological uh
advancements they're the ones a part of
the fourth Industrial Revolution
creating this situation where we have
the haves and haves not I just want to
point this out though I don't believe
the the end result that these people are
preaching is the appropriate response
but I certainly think there is a
cognitive dissonance in complaining
about the woke cult but then also saying
there aren't useless people out there I
guess you can say that the woke cult is
the useful people for these these
autocrats and dictatorial warmongers
they want a Mindless zombie horde to do
their bidding but I look at it like we I
think we do have a problem I'm not going
to sit here and tell you I know
everything about climate change I don't
I think it's it's plausible that over
consumption can lead to any kind of
pollution or environmental disruption I
think that's a fair point I'm not going
to pretend like I know enough and I
don't trust people who buy beachfront
property and then tell me to sell you
know sell my car or whatever but I also
think you go to these big cities and you
will see nothing but useless people and
I'm not trying to be a dick I'm not
trying they don't have to be useless but
the problem is many of them are listless
and purposeless and then they seek out
authoritarianism they support the worst
of the worst ideologies they actively
disrupt and Destroy so not that I agree
with that guy who's kind of a
nightmarish despot I do think it's
important to point out we have a
cultural problem in the U.S where we
have a large swath of people who don't
contribute anything but just drag the
system down combine that with the fact
that they also don't have a God right so
they they they get behind let's say it's
the work religion or the
environmentalist religion all these
different quasi pseudo-religions filling
the void and they have meaningless logic
it's a serious issue that we have to
address we have to find create
meaningful lives for people so in that
sense much as you all Nova Noah Harari
puts my back up and get very nervous of
the stuff he says that I think you're
right we have a meaning meaning
purpose crisis in the west let me let's
let's pull up this story from the
post-millennial check this out video
shows reinstated Tennessee State Rep
Justin Jones stopping cars and
assaulting drivers in the summer of
2020. this is what I'm talking about so
we we were just talking about this idea
of useless people you've got two trains
of thought happening right now this uh
what's Yuval Harare is that his name yes
he's talking about these useless eaters
but these are like the Davos group
people who are more you know I don't
know comic book of villainy but I do
think that there may be a separate
perspective on how to deal with the
problem their view I think is dark the
global the Davos group all the stuff
there like you will owe nothing and
you'll be happy my view of dealing with
the useless eaters or whatever it is he
calls them is to provide purpose and
meaning exactly so I look at this story
this story is extremely important
because this is an elected Democrat
State Rep I believe yes State Rep who is
attacking vehicles in the summer of 2020
and then gets elected
to office this guy
reportedly assaulted members of the
Tennessee Tennessee legislature in 2019
throwing coffee at them hot coffee and
was banned from the Capitol Building he
is a violent extremist who now holds a
seat of power and when he was expelled
for joining the Insurrection the
Tennessee Capital they reinstate him I
do not see our system maintaining itself
if these people are taking seats of
power and I warned this would happen in
2018. people told me I was crazy when I
said this stuff will reach the highest
levels of government next stop federal
government and what happens when you
have antifa violent anti-fuck extremists
getting elected to congress which is
already on the horizon I mean AOC is on
the borderline of being a far left
extremist granted she still plays ball
with the establishment but next up the
next four years the next eight years
we're going to start seeing Psychopaths
like this sitting in the Senate and
they're going to be advocating and
defending more violence like this then
the system breaks one of the things and
there's a lot about this story that's
that's shocking but that this story is
only really covered as far as I could
find on the post-millennial if this was
the opposite party it would be not only
Legacy of mainstream media Across
America it would be worldwide news that
is imagine that there was a republican
who was involved in January 6th actually
part of that we would never hear the end
of it they tried making it the narrative
saying that people like Marjorie Taylor
green was giving tours or something
trying to insinuate that there was
pre-planning on behalf of the
Republicans which is all just utter
nonsense but yes if this was any
Republican it would be International and
why don't the Democrats just come out
and condemn it it's simple condemn it
get and then they'll they'll look more
reasonable you know what I think have
you seen kingsman the first one the
movie years ago so the villain is a tech
billionaire who believes the world is
overpopulated so he wants to preserve
all of the wealthy individuals that he
likes and gives them these devices to
protect them and then gives away free
cell phones which when he can press a
button they'll emit a sound that makes
everybody go crazy and kill each other
it's really funny how they make this
movie and this guy is like the Earth is
overpopulated so it's giving itself a
fever and it's killing everybody that's
basically how he talks I'm imitating him
and so the premise of the movie is Tech
billionaire wants to kill billions of
people to save the Earth
then you look at stuff like this and
you're like why is it that you know
these Davos group individuals these
billionaires and these Democrats
don't understand that their policies
destroy cities that they're supporting
violent people why is it that you get a
video of a dude filling a black garbage
bag with products at a Walgreens
and you can't do anything to stop them
it's like because they're on the side of
the villain in the movie Kingsman their
mentality is let the system be destroyed
by itself to save the planet Tim I think
you're onto something quite interesting
there philosophically because most of
the great evils if if not the vast
majority
taken out in the world were people who
philosophically believed they were doing
the right thing the Communist Stalin
thought he was doing the right thing I'm
sure there were Psychopaths amongst them
perhaps Hitler was one the Nazis they
thought they were doing the right thing
and that's how they're able to do such
evil if you believe you're doing in
doing the right thing you can do the
work the absolute unimaginable
atrocities and and I think that analogy
of the kingsman probably asked for that
and that and that's just it these people
they think they're doing good the
useless eaters that that guy describes
this is how he views them and so what
better way to reduce you know the saying
is you are the carbon they are trying to
reduce what better way than let the
system Fall Apart
stop maintaining it let it fall and
you'll cut population down or at least
population growth and I'll put it this
way Bill Gates is a TED Talk where he
says if we work hard enough in these
areas we can reduce population growth by
what do you say like 10 or 15 or
something like that now a lot of people
immediately came out and said he's
talking about reducing population by 10
or 15 percent no no I said population
growth his whole bit publicly is too
many people are coming too fast let's
slow that down but of course that's the
opposite is true by the way well my
point is that position makes no sense
you can't be like we have too many
people let's just have too many people
slower you either think there's too many
people and there should be less of them
or you don't think there's too many
people but continue well the the the
real problem and the thing that I am
most concerned about everything is
population decline that we are we're
going to have an aging population with
and this is happening now and across the
world where uh I think most of the
countries if I'm not mistaken you might
need to fact check me on this are now
our population growth is in Decline so
even in in Africa now the uh the average
amount of children per family has gone
from seven to four I say and then and
it's going in that direction what you're
then going to have is uh uh an old
population who are not working having to
be supported by the working population
which is getting smaller and smaller and
smaller and what happens in that that
old people die all people well all
people die but it it continues that
phenomenon continues as the population
of the clients in fact Hungary is the
only country in the world that are
implementing policy to encourage mothers
to have more children and that is should
be far more concerning to the elite not
hungry
is that right why would it be concerning
to the people who want less people the
global Elites the people like Bill Gates
Who come out and say there should be
less people are probably happy to hear
that there's less people and I think the
answer to this is very very simple for
anybody who's listening there's two
things you can do everyone says Tim what
can I do I hear about all these bad
things things what is going on here two
very very simple things you can do the
first don't buy Anheuser-Busch products
no more Budweiser no more Bud Light I
think michelob's in there Modelo
shinerbach get it all out of there
figure it out and buy a different beer
brand it sounds absurd but that's true
but more importantly the real point I
was gonna make is have a bunch of babies
what you mentioned 10 babies what you
mentioned is is happening but it's
happening on a grander level in the
western world uh so so populations
aren't replacing the population that uh
is is dying off especially in places
like Europe especially in places like
Japan and these crashes are going to
have significant ramifications not just
for the economy but for society in large
and when you look at the actual numbers
you look at the actual stats we're not
dealing with too many people we're
dealing with a problem that's going to
be very severe because of too little of
people and Elon Musk talks about this
all the time Bill Gates still for some
reason still Cloud Schwab and a lot of
Elites too many people in this world and
when you look at all these kind of soft
policies when you look at policies that
could be described as fifth generational
Warfare especially when it comes to
people not having a family unit
especially when it comes to people
cutting off their reproductive organs
when it comes to people being poisoned
by microplastics or seed oils or
chemicals that are incentivized and of
course paid for by tax subsidies all of
those things correls under situations
and circumstances where people are less
fertile having less babies having less
families and and this is really reaching
a crescendo moment that's going to be
tragic not only for the future
Generations but the future of the earth
which is going to have civilizational
collapse very soon if this is not
addressed and the only countries
addressing it is Hungary Poland and
China that I've seen personally we don't
need the government to address it we
need honest moral people with good
morals to just have babies we need both
but I also say there's geopolitical
ramifications as well Louise Perry has
just written about this and unheard at
the currently South Korea is in massive
population decline North Korea is still
growing so we'll be in a position and I
forget in how many decades but not very
long where North Korea's population will
be twice as much as South Korea they'll
be able to walk in they'll just take
over it's it's it's
geopolitically it's a massive issue it's
a huge issue it's going to be tragic
it's going to be absolutely horrible
because the trajectory that we're going
on especially with not just the
reproductive care or abortion but but
more specifically with with testosterone
levels and sperm levels dropping
dramatically to the point where it's
shocking where where people and some
experts are saying we could soon reach a
point in time in our lifetimes where
where males can't reproduce there's a
there's a crazy visualization surge I
don't know if you can pull this up but
it's a if you search Engadget humans in
a pile it's it's basically a
visualization of of what all the humans
if they were just put into a pile would
look like oh like where it's like a big
Mound yeah it's like a big Mound yeah
and it's just you know there's a lot of
people here it's not no but the point
being it's not that much space Here's oh
right right yeah here's here's here's
what I think is is going on I think
these powerful Davos type Elites don't
really care all that much about too many
people they care specifically about the
useless eaters yeah if these people were
all doing functional tasks then we would
have like I'll put it this way maybe
they don't please I don't know these
people seem to be crazy and out of their
minds if every person on this planet had
a specialty and filled the quota of
their uh economic
um requirement meaning
let's say Earth could handle you know
100 million uh rocket Engineers if every
single person if every single job and
that was was filled and every single
person was doing a legitimate job that
advanced human civilization we would be
colonizing other planets already we'd be
true we'd have warp drive the problem is
large portions of humans on this planet
do nothing and that's what these people
think they become nightmarish despotic
Psychopaths who think let's just get rid
of people where the solution is we
should educate the Next Generation give
them purpose and give them morals and
craft the the uh mechanisms by which
humans become
useful that's actually what they want I
think and what the concern is is the age
of automation is we're entering a fourth
Industrial Revolution now where
artificial intelligence is taking over
people's jobs we'll have less need for
human labor and they are very concerned
about the useless eaters revolting or
losing their mind they don't have enough
this happened with the luddites what
exactly Industrial Revolution people are
like I will not have this and then you
get the luddites people who just oppose
the advancements I I kind of disagree
with you guys I I think they're more of
a destructive force I think they're more
sociopathic I think they're more
deranged than you guys give them credit
to because even if everyone was was
productive and had a purpose and had a
belief system and all that I I think
throughout human history there have
always been a group of individuals or
one individual trying to take control of
the entire world I think this is what
it's really about at the end of the day
I think it's about control I think it's
about enslavement no matter what we do
they're always going to be there is
always going to be a group of
sociopathic individuals trying to
control everything for themselves either
for demonic reasons sure
now we'll stop and ask ourselves
what is going through their mind if that
is the case what is their goal and what
is their desire is their desire
something as one-dimensional as I just
want to control things or is their goal
something like I want there's eternal
life there's a there's another aspect to
it I think this applies to Davis Davos
it's the banality banality of evil which
is that you have for example Davos you
have a lot of politicians who are
thinking what am I going to do after I
I'm kicked out of office I need a
high-paying job and then you have a lot
of the corporates who are there who have
a ton of money but don't have the power
that the politicians have so they want
to be there so they have their own
individual personal Ambitions which is
driving them there they might not be
thinking how do I control the world they
are some of them I'm sure are thinking
that but I think a lot of them are
thinking how do I make my life better
and so they go along with what ends up
being evil uh
sort of phenomenon of the evil uh groups
like that I have a feeling if we do
create purpose and productivity that it
will take some of the burden off of
Klaus Schwab's mind because I I don't
look at him as like a a violent
psychopath that wants to burn I think
they're trying to prevent World War III
and they're desperate and so they're
like put them in pods I don't know what
what but it doesn't matter
the doubt at the very least I disagree
look at this guy attacking the motorist
right this guy thinks he's stopping
world war three this guy thinks he's
stopping climate change but he's clearly
a deranged psychopath who's doing
nothing but attacking random innocent
motorists yeah now Cloud Schwab's no
different yeah he thinks he's doing good
but what he doesn't maybe doesn't know
or he's taking a risk on is it
centralizing Authority has never really
worked on the human but it has always
been something that many people have
tried to achieve throughout human
history and no matter how many people
they slaughter and enslave that is
always their end goal and has always
been their end goal and to think that
this doesn't exist now when it existed
all throughout human history is very
naive because now with the technology
now with so much power with so much
influence it's so much wealth
concentrated against so many few
individuals they have an abundant amount
of resources they have Quantum Computing
they have artificial intelligence they
have new technology that could
essentially help them live forever while
everyone else is going to be of course
enslaved to this system that they're
building all around us and when we look
at what they're incentivizing and we
look at what they're are attacking what
are they attacking they're attacking
religion they're attacking purpose
they're attacking labor they're
attacking the middle class they're
attacking any human beings being
productive doing the good things what
are they incentivizing social justice
Warrior woke causes like this they're
incentivizing a divide and conquer
agenda that has people fighting each
other they're in incentivizing a system
that is essentially order out of chaos
and creating this horrible situation
where we're fighting each other and not
even having real deep discussions about
how big the rabbit hole goes and who's
really in charge because they don't want
to be challenged exactly you're right
about the control but I think they're
more like the villain from Kingsman they
want people to erase themselves yeah my
question though and they are who's they
I mean it's kind of tongue-in-chief
exactly like it maybe has one motive but
Xi Jinping has another motive and Joe
Biden's has a motive and and Putin
together like maybe one of them is a
violence like Mafia crime families but
they understand that if one family or if
something else threatens the the
alliance or the game that they're
playing playing that they take them out
so when you look at everything it's it's
multiple factors it's it's multiple
organizations working together and they
have a shared goal and obviously
sometimes they fight within each other
but they always make sure that the game
continues and the game is rigged against
you one of the uh reasons that they I
that the problems they identify are for
example not poverty but inequality or
let's say it's the environmental crisis
is because those are issues that cannot
be solved the problems that they
identify that cannot be solved from the
ground up rather that we need to hand
over our power to the technocrats they
and that's maybe where the power thing
comes into play that I think I probably
agree with you as they're funneling and
fueling the problems look at what George
Soros and how much money he's throwing
at District Attorneys what has been the
cause of George Soros spending about a
million dollars on every district
attorney what has happened what's
happening in America I read the story
earlier there's a mass Exodus out of New
York and there's a mass uh migration to
Florida they say just in the first
quarter 10 000 people swapped their New
York State IDs for Florida IDs New
York's in a state of decay hasn't that
happened since covet there was there's
hundreds of hundreds of thousands all of
these all of these Democrat cities are
just ripping themselves apart they vote
blue and then they don't like the
policies and they leave but but it's
it's remarkable that there is no way in
my mind the mayor uh you know people
like de Blasio and now Adams that the
mayor's or or you know who who's the
current mayor of LA but you had I think
was Garcetti during a lockdown there's
no way they did not know what they were
doing like I just don't Gavin Newsom for
instance he goes to Florida do you guys
see this video yeah he goes to Florida
and he says authoritarian regime
DeSantis Banning books he knows he's
lying like there's no way he actually
believes the things he says which means
the only conclusion is they're all evil
he was arresting people for running
running businesses for having a
restaurant that was open he was
arresting people just for trying to live
in and survive in the state of
California and he has the balls to go to
Florida and say Santa says it's a what I
mean it's just so on your face it's so
ridiculous that that is I gotta say
though guys insane if you're aware of
what's going on then you've already
started making your plans to get away
from these cities you've left these
cities you've maybe gone to Florida or
Texas or a rural area you've perhaps
purchased some chickens which are now
creating more of themselves it's a
really amazing thing they do not only do
they make food for you but that food
could actually turn into more of them
which can then make more exponentially
so you're aware of what's going on
you're protecting yourself you're
learning you're having a family you're
taking your kids out of school the end
result of this is the policies enacted
by democrats is just causing harm to
their own constituents They are
promoting policies that sterilize their
constituents that cause their
constituents to abort and destroy their
own children and then they bring about
corruption in their own cities it's
almost like this imagine there was a
civil war happening imagine there was an
actual Civil War and it was Republican
versus Democrats left versus right
I couldn't ask of anything more of
Democrats right if you're if you're on
the right and you are like we are going
to war here's my plan we will infiltrate
the seats of government in our opponents
cities and then enact policies that will
erode and destroy those cities and cause
their citizens to flee to us then we
will control like they're
self-destructing themselves and it all
like if you could if you told me what
happened was Republicans infiltrated
Democrat cities to destroy them I'd be
like well they're doing a good job of it
I can't see I why else would they do
these things that's my point Gavin
Newsom knows he's lying he knows he's
destroying things you can't look at that
they have a map you can look up for San
Francisco that shows you where all the
poop is I'm not exaggerating it's true
that's true it's it's like someone took
Google Google Maps and then they made uh
you know you could do a plug-in or
whatever yeah the heat is emitting no it
shows little brown brown uh pins it's
like ways you tag it there's brown paper
you tag it yes and so what happens is
someone when they see poop they'll they
will write down the address and put it
in the map and so the whole of San
Francisco is one it's all brown because
every inch of it is covered in these
pins
Gavin Newsom Nancy Pelosi these people
know that that that that is a problem
they don't care this is the party they
do nothing to stop it I get start to get
nauseous at this point of the
conversation because I had a crazy dream
last night a crazy dream but I was the
president and we were like we did it we
finally did it let's go we're gonna go
sign the let's go sign the paperwork in
your office and we I walk into my office
and a guy points a gun at me and shoots
me in the heart like as I walked in you
cannot defeat the military-industrial
complex it cannot be stopped so it's
either get along or throw your body away
is where I'm at other than that I'm just
like let's just jam and make some hot
music and maybe we can convince
everybody that way because even Cloud
Schwab Likes music they have those weird
singers that those weird musicians but
when that happened the guy shot me in
the heart I said this is a dream and
it's my dream so I'm rewinding this and
then I went back and got the guy's name
and it started with an S uh it was a
very very disconcerting dream and it led
me to think that if I pursue the
political solution I will be offed by
the by the system but there are other
ways to solve this and a lot of it is
local governance and taking care of your
family and your neighborhood but I think
you need to be aggressively creative I
think that's a bit for me anyway that's
my path
I agree with you on that there's a lot
the political stuff you know they're all
Liars but if you actually just
start with loving your neighbor just
start at home that's a bloody good start
and if everyone just started at home
thinking who Who's On My Street who can
I help let's do this let's look after
our family that's how you actually
defeat it the opposite and forgive me if
I get a bit churchy Lads but the
opposite of all this stuff or stuff is
it's the church it's scripture it's the
Bible that's literally the opposite
that's how you defeat it but yeah I mean
no you're not changing anybody's mind if
you can't have a good relationship with
your family at home on Thanksgiving
dinner it's like being able to have
conversations at home with your parents
who you completely disagree with like
you have to have that skill you're
doomed without it and no one can there's
so many people who are abandoning their
parents you know just you know talk of
like trying to do all this change
politics you're you're absolutely right
though let's start by make amends with
your family that since 2016 you're not
able to have Thanksgiving anymore
because they've got what the wrong
opinion like one's a tough oh no the
ones work oh no actually maybe try mend
that first worry about politics
here's the issue though uh Jack euger
had a masterful tweet today and many
people listening may be gasping or
spitting out their water having heard me
say that he said that I'll paraphrase
the right is willing to accept anyone
who agrees so much as five percent with
them whereas the left will excise anyone
who disagrees with 0.05 percent of their
position and he's completely correct The
Young Turks are getting have been
relentlessly slammed because Anna
kasparian said don't call me a birthing
person I bring this up because you're
talking about you know mending that
divide and everything but I got to tell
you man I think a lot of people listen
have have tried to be that reasonable
person talking to someone who is woke or
in the cult and saying something as
simple as like well let's talk about it
and they just get angry and say no yeah
you gotta make them the center of
attention it's kind of like you gotta
let them be selfish for a moment a lot
of people in the not just a moment it
can take years but it's it's it's it's
the issue is it's worth it if you have
if you have a a relative who is a Turf
you know that's called trans
exclusionary radical feminist I I want
to point this out by the way they call
anyone who is like against gender
ideology a Turf even if they're not
feminists like
these conservative women are not
feminists okay so don't call them that
but I call them something else but uh my
point is this if I I guarantee you 100
if you sit down with someone who is
described as a turf they're going to
have a conversation with you about what
they think and why they think it if you
sit down with someone who we would
describe as woke 95 of the time they
will get emotional angry and reject the
the the argument outright or just refuse
to sit down with you at all in those
situations I find if you can stay calm
it's kind of like it erodes their anger
uh it takes time and patience but if
someone's freaking out and you stay calm
the entire it's it's contagious no it
makes them really angry actually at
First maybe well this is this is like a
common well-known thing in in debate
that if your opponent is getting
flustered and you lower your tone and
get more calm they get it actually in
inverts and makes them angrier but the
Assumption you're making is that the
conversation you're having is about the
politics or about the philosophy what
about actually trying to regain remember
all those other things that we have in
common and maybe just let's not talk
about politics for a couple years let's
just remember there are more important
things than politics importance as
politics are important as these issues
are on a family level okay let's do
let's talk about let's talk about
Football let's talk about some of those
deeper things well let me let me give
you scenario then and ask your thoughts
on this I brought this up a couple weeks
ago when I was hanging out in a poker
room and the guy on my left were playing
a table it's a nine player game
funny guy we are laughing having a good
time whenever you play at these tables
your side of the tables are whispering
to each other the other side's
whispering and we got this guy who is
bluffing like crazy so the dude to my
left starts making some jokes I'm
laughing with him he's nudging me and
saying look what he's doing and we're ha
ha ha ha ha
then politics comes up because of the
economy naturally when you're playing a
game that involves money and it got to
the point where he said that he thought
the January 6th defendant should all be
executed for treason
and I'm like okay here's a guy who is
laughing with me we're having a good
time man we're almost friends and then
he says something as terrifying as that
how am I supposed to like I'll be honest
this guy was telling me a story about a
dude who was criminally charged because
uh antifa surrounded his car he fled and
then got charged with attempted murder
because he hit people as he was fleeing
and so I was like you should put me in
touch with this guy like let's talk and
he goes yeah it's BS that they did to
this guy and I'm like okay so me and
this guy got something to agree on and
maybe we can solve these issues
and and I would say the majority of our
interaction was not political at all the
moment he said he wanted he believed
that they should execute these guys I'm
like
I don't think so in that scenario you
don't have you're not going to actually
achieve anything by talking about that
which is why I try to persuade it so
what you can just do is ask them loads
of questions try and work out why it is
that he's come to that conclusion and
maybe in asking the questions that he
hasn't been asked by anyone because he
hasn't met someone with different
political positions or different
opinions he might go home and be like
you know what maybe I was a bit wrong
with that you don't have to you don't
have to persuade him in the moment just
ask him the question because by the way
it's also interesting like an extremist
like that like how do you come to that
that's quite interesting and this is
this is like a regular guy I think he
said he worked construction who's
playing a game of poker having a laugh
on his day off and then all of a sudden
he says something as Extreme as that and
that was like she's probably just
regurgitating it from you know he got
his Circle I got friends
this is the thing like he got so angry
about it is why I was just like okay
like I'm gonna I'm Gonna Leave This guy
be because you know I I asked him when
he said that I was like really executed
wow he said it in a different way I'll
mind you he said in a very very gruesome
and graphic way to put it simply and uh
my response was uh did you hear about
what happened on May 29th with the the
the the left is the White House and he
goes no I don't think about that and I
was like they they set St John's Church
on fire and they you know the pr Trump
was forced into bunker he goes I don't
know what you're talking about these
people I'm telling you it's they were
traitors and I'm just like I'm done I'm
not I mean he's invented well because
now he might a month later he might have
his brain perhaps and he'll have to deal
with that and I'm sure there'll be
cognitive dissonance and and might he
might have to do that unpacking by
himself and it might be quite painful
for that fella to do that unpacking but
you might have planted the seed I think
that's the correct way to deal with it
or or you doubled down on his extremism
go even further
well it's a plan maybe we should maybe
we should treat their children just like
Barack Obama treated the children in the
Middle East and bombed them during their
wedding that's that actually is so that
is a persuasion technique I have talked
about before it's called Rapport extreme
turn where in order to change someone's
mind you have to approach them from
further than their own position so it's
it's a really basic manipulation
technique the general idea is for the
first thing if someone presents to you
an idea that you disagree with the first
thing is Rapport you completely agree
with it now in their minds this lowers
their defenses and they feel like you're
part of their same tribe the second is
the extreme like Luke said you double
down and go further than they would find
reasonable forcing them in the other
direction yeah it shows them where they
may end up if they stay on the path of
extremism you're like okay I see where
what you mean or just how ridiculous
this is or just this question their
original stance it's actually much
simpler than that you make yourself
their ideological opponent in the other
direction which forces them in your
direction you know I have friends that
say kind of stuff like your that guy you
were talking about Tim just weird
extreme things about racism like friends
from over the years and I realized like
I can handle in a conversation and you
can easily ask questions and get past it
and find out the psychology but when
people post those things on social media
in text they get ripped out of context
and hot the person for their entire
medium the texts social media absolutely
not the media if you can't avoid doing
it I think it has to be the best face to
face but even a phone call is better you
just there's so much in tone you lose
Friends by text if you have those
conversations I've actually written off
talking about politics and tax that's a
wise principle to
have I think it's it's helpful well it's
similar to how like if you're walking
down the street in New York City and you
see people handing out propaganda or you
know just crazy people mouthing off like
people will just walk by crazy people in
New York City they're not they wouldn't
ask them to get banned from the street
corner necessarily but if you see a
social media post you go completely
insane wow so
let me I'll tell you I'll tell you
another story I was in I think Luke was
actually there uh uh I think you are I'm
not sure we were in New York during a
stop fascism protest you're probably
there because you're at I'm always yeah
yeah you're at everything on that and
I'm not everything in Europe uh it was a
it was it was called like refuse fascism
or something like this it's an
organization associated with revcom
revolutionary communists and so I see
this woman I'm just out there filming
and I'm like just seeing what's up I
can't I think this might have been like
2017 or 2018. I see this woman holding a
sign that says stop fascisms or whatever
and I'm filming so I say ma'am is it all
right if I'm I'm doing a live stream is
it okay if I ask some questions and
she's like yes of course and I'm like do
I just explain uh you know why you came
out today and what your sign means and
then she's like yes you know I think
blah Blanche explains all this stuff and
then I said uh you know
I forgot how I said it but I was very
much just like some of the activists
here that have organized this are with
an organization called revcom I'm
curious if you are here just for stop
fascism or refuse fascism or if you
actually came out with the Revolutionary
Communist party and she snapped started
screaming at me calling me Fox News but
what I said was a legitimate question
that was true revcom was there they were
the ones that gave her the sign she was
waving their sign and when I simply
asked her I was like did you come out
here in support of them or is it just
about fascism she snapped and started
screaming and totally shut down no more
logical discussion I couldn't even get a
regular question at that point so there
are people who are like
I don't know what it is you know and I
was just like I'm sorry for asking it is
best to start with your family people
that you have something in contact with
and then it's kind of like training a
muscle I think you mentioned that
earlier bill it's like a it's like a
skill you need to have to succeed in
life is to be able to ask questions to
probe
things you disagree with and genuinely
listen to that empathize with people
um well because the moment you have to
disattach from an outcome of changing
their mind exactly exactly if you want
to do that then people can sense it and
even if they want to agree with you they
won't agree with you if they feel like
you're trying to pressure them into
thinking what they thought they might
double down if they feel pressured so
that's what happened to Kanye well so we
wanted to double down because he's fed
up with everyone telling him you can't
think that so this is this is the issue
with a lot of many things that I went to
college the basic manipulation right
I've talked about this a lot over the
years
um because I used to hang out at
hackerspace as social engineering is
like a principal uh subset of the hacker
community of hacker of I don't know
whatever you'd call it
whenever you hear about a big story
about someone getting hacked it's
usually social engineering the
manipulation of a human being into
giving up access or information or
something like that and in that you
learn a lot about this stuff here's the
challenge I find
knowing how to manipulate someone's
position I find to be the dark side
actively going to someone and then
pulling off that trick or poor extreme
turn to me is evil you are you are
tricking someone into doing something
that you want them to do I believe the
good thing to do is provide them with an
opportunity and information and be a
reasonable understanding human being and
let them be a free individual who
decides for themself the problem the
other side uses those technique
techniques on regular people and that's
why it's so difficult hence why you you
see things like with uh Kyle Rittenhouse
for instance the media lies the
Covington kids the media lies Justice
Millet they lie we hear I I always look
at it like this we've decided to play a
game of Monopoly the left and the right
and we are watching the left pull bills
out of the bank and they just keep
saying what are you going to do about it
and we're like guess I'll just keep
playing can't understand why I keep
losing though that's the challenge the
the you know there's the there's
different modes for it right because
there's the there's the dinner table
where where you should go into the
conversation thinking I might actually
learn something they might be right
about something that I'm wrong about
which by the way for the dinner table is
an important person's coming and then
there's the political level and I I
don't think it's right to conflate the
two because it's a different you should
have a different mindset going into both
agreed agree yeah
so you think that game theory playing it
out you know good faith and bad faith
bad faith will eventually Stomp over the
good faith I mean
I don't know if it's allude but I'll put
it this way if uh if you're gonna go if
you and Ian we're gonna race a foot race
you know 100 meter sprint or something
and Ian's wearing rollerblades are you
gonna be like I might be able to win
this one I mean honestly I don't know
you might be able to yeah
it's been about 30 years and he's got a
hundred millimeter Wheels they're real
big real fast I played hockey I would
kill you okay you're like let's race and
he's riding a bike you're like okay like
how am I supposed to win this if you're
riding a bike and I'm running and I'm
trying to be honest and you're cheating
I think if people know that they're
being cheated or that they're using some
dark energy to convince them then they
will revolt and embrace the light side
but if they don't know that's when the
dark will overcome then then maybe the
simple thing is not to argue with people
about their political perspective but to
show them an instance where the media
lied and that's just about it meaning so
you can ask them be like oh yeah tell me
about that I no I genuinely want to hear
more and then when they say something
that is you know to be factually false
you can go you can say something like oh
wasn't no I heard about that one pull it
up on your phone and be like I think
that's no I think that one wasn't true
and shown and be proactive don't wait
because I had a conversation with my mom
about Robert F Kennedy Jr who she loves
and is always loved and I was like
really early on I said get ready watch
what the media is going to do because
they I saw two articles where they said
anti-vaxx right she's like yeah yeah but
if I'd waited six months to have that
conversation she'd already be
indoctrinated by that media so I was
able to kind of
cut it off at the at the turn kind of
wrapped it yeah like get ready that you
might see some subterfuge coming were
you about maybe it's as simple as just
like when you're at the dinner table you
can be like I don't want to argue you
know you're probably right about a whole
bunch of stuff can I just show you this
one thing and then show them like where
the media lied in a modern instance
about something significant and then be
like I'm not here to tell you what to
think what to believe I just want you to
see this the crazy thing is the left
accuses the media of lying all the time
but for some reason they March in
lockstep with these narratives because
that this is the challenge I I think
that's why I call it a cult you know how
do you break someone from a cult here's
the real challenge I think we have
the reason why they are likely not going
to care about your arguments we're
approaching this and I think this is
unfortunate but we approach this from
our personal biases which is you know we
think we can have a reason discussion
with someone perhaps planting the seed
of an idea may change their mind but
what's being omitted from that concept
that conversation is that these people
are seeking only likes and retweets
that's it they don't care about whether
or not they're proving something to be
true or solving a problem they care if
they get social gratification again
you're now in the Twitter medium right
and you're this is like social media as
we as we discussed these all of these
distant scenarios uh what I'm on
different behavioral right right what I
mean though is it's not I'm I'm using
social media as the vehicle to explain
the average person who sits down like
let's say you sit down with your family
members there's a reason why they hold
these views it's because you are the
summation of The Five People You
surround yourself with they're not going
to want to agree with you they will
reject what you say because in three
hours they will once again be surrounded
by cult members who will reinforce all
of their thinking and they will reject
what you said the the challenge is how
do you get someone out of a cult add a
top layer to that their phones keep them
connected to the cult 24 7. what do you
do I think that the likes and shares is
kind of an empty purpose it's definitely
there's a you know there's some there's
something to getting rich but
being being listened to is I think more
fulfilling than getting 100 likes so
that's why verbalizing and listening is
so important with family and friends I I
do think it's it's I I think there are a
lot of regular people who believe false
things and they're not woke right this
is a thing too uh I will say fair points
to Winston in that a lot of the context
of what I'm talking about specifically
refers to people who are politically
initiated but there are a lot of people
who I would refer to as uninitiated who
believe what we it's what Andrew
Breitbart called default liberal who
will be willing to listen to things even
if they're a little hostile at first
because it sounds foreign to them but
eventually will be a lot you know you
were right about that you know it that
is to say the left wins a lot because
regular people who don't pay attention
will just vote their way because they
don't pay attention and if we do speak
to many of these people and we are calm
and reasonable we end up finding that
maybe it's only 10 20 or 30 percent of
these people aren't actually
indoctrinated aren't actually woke they
just don't know anything at all
absolutely I think that's I in fact that
would have been the case for me and I
can think of examples in my history
where I just had default normally
positions without having really thought
about them and then when someone
challenged me and I actually thought
about it that's when I changed my mind I
think you're absolutely right people go
along with it yeah I wonder if we had
that moment with uh for those who saw
the member segment when I was ranting
about Ukraine with Dr Peter pogosian
I'll just say Man the War stuff triggers
me that's if if like the one thing that
takes me from calm to like cranked up to
11 is people trying to justify foreign
intervention and War and all that stuff
they'll use it against you or just
blowing people up and murdering human
beings that that is the epitome of
absolute just immoral wrong on on this
Earth there's nothing that gets me
angrier than people who support say like
what you want you want to trigger me
come up to me and ignorantly just try to
justify the war in Ukraine without
knowing anything about it and I'm just
gonna be like
you're out of your mind do you ever use
other tactics to manipulate them I know
it sounds cold but like I'll just have a
straightforward argument and if they if
they don't like you know when I used to
do the nonprofit fundraising it was all
pure manipulation they trained you to
manipulate they tell you to manipulate
and then eventually it's just like this
is not good like going out and
convincing people to be part of a cause
by tricking them is not a good thing and
I and I don't want to be part of that
okay what's I mean sorry here's a
question so if you're saying that you
should not be able to be pro-war in the
in Ukraine or whichever War without
being knowledgeable about it do you also
think that you should not be able to be
anti-war in Ukraine without being
knowledgeable about it so anti-war it's
okay to not be knowledgeable yes okay
yes simply put if you're saying hey I
would like to uh blow up this this other
this far away land it's like well look I
gotta be honest I don't know anything
about that so I'm going to air on the
side if we shouldn't blow people up
until proven guilty yeah yeah if you
can't provide me with a justification
for why you're blowing people up I'm not
going to agree with you on it but I mean
look people who watch the show know me
I'm they call me milk toast fence sitter
as kind of like and and the origin of
that is someone commented on a video
calling me that and I totally went with
it I was like yes absolutely because
there's too much I don't know so I'm not
going to come out and be like this is
definitively true it's like well
honestly I don't know I mean if if I see
a video of it happening I'll I'll be
more inclined to believe it and say hey
look there's a video of this Democrat
guy attacking people he was criminally
charged for doing it stands to reason
it's likely true but for all I know is a
guy wearing a mask I don't know you know
pretending to be him I really doubt it
though you know Occam's razor suggests
this dude was attacking people but I'm
not I'm not gonna just come out and be
like everyone else that it's true
therefore it is you know yeah there's so
much media manipulation it seems like
our goal our job I can't speak for
everyone but is to keep people calm is
to like create like a spiritual realm
that we can all coexist in maybe it's
just mine I don't know you have a great
opportunity you like bring Intel like
intellect or like bring information to
people that I appreciate I like to make
people calm while they learn the
information but I'm less focused on the
actual information more on how the you
feel when you learn it well a lot of
people are being Hoodwinked they're
being conned there's so much emotional
manipulation there's so many psyops and
and I wish people would just realized
your neighbor is not your enemy the the
Republican down the street is not trying
trying to hurt you or kill you but they
have convinced so many human beings that
that the person opposite of you living
next to you or might believe something
politically is somehow your greatest
danger to your existence that's not true
and I think it's solely done on purpose
so we don't realize who is or what is
the purpose and and the reason why
people are suffering and dealing with so
much pain and grief and and pain and
suffering in their life uh and and when
you truly do kind of look at it I I
think one of the biggest Solutions is
just being the best version of yourself
being personally responsible being happy
and being healthy and I think doing
those things is a modern day Act of
resistance against our modern system and
modern society which thrives off of
negativity and hatred and and bigotry
and just ignorance and I think the more
we strive to be better the more we
Inspire others to do the same and I
think the small decisions forget about
trying to change other people change
yourself try to make yourself the best
version of yourself try to make yourself
an individual who doesn't buy in to the
psyops doesn't buy the bull crap doesn't
give your money to those evil beings
those evil creatures those entities and
demons that of course Thrive off of
screwing you over and I and I think if
we really kind of self-reflect more that
would be a lot better than just being
like you do what I want you to do and I
think we need more yeah Luke man you put
your money where your mouth is because
that that event today that Gathering was
incredible it just there's a power of
meeting with other like-minded
individuals just like the event that you
know you guys are putting on tomorrow
and and Bill you're putting on Saturday
there's a power with individuals coming
together there's an energy there there's
a frequency there uh and you know we
could get all hippie dippy but there's a
congruence there is a combining of those
energies that is very powerful this is
why we are starting we are we are
launching a coffee shop
it's going to be in West Virginia the
plans have already been drawn up the
contractor has been contracted and we're
preparing plumbing and all that stuff
the idea that we had was you want to
solve these problems a lot of ways you
can do it you can have a family you can
have kids you can get away from cities
homeschool your kids all that good stuff
that's a powerful thing you can do right
now and don't forget don't buy Bud Light
or Anheuser-Busch products now the other
thing we're doing I hope my vision in
five years 50 coffee shops around the
United States in or in in in semi-urban
maybe Suburban areas cast brew coffee
when you walk in the front door and you
walk up to the counter to buy coffee
there's a little seating area and
there's a TV with Stephen Crowder
playing on it there's a TV with Viva and
barns with 6X and Hammer with Tim cast
IRL with we are change and people will
walk in and they'll be sitting down and
they'll be seeing their coffee and
they'll be looking up and they'll just
possibly be watching these shows we do
that we launch a thousand of these
coffee shops we start franchising them
and then we put our perspectives in
shopping centers
the other component is to start once we
get this one up and running we'll uh the
first thing I'm going to do is
investigate franchising because that's
probably the fastest and easiest way to
make these things exist everywhere I
don't need to be the CEO of a massive
multinational corporation of you know of
coffee shops I want coffee shops to
exist where like-minded individuals can
come get together and have a cup of
coffee and we can guarantee the
expansion of ideas like ours or Crowders
or Luke's Etc and and all of the minds
creators who are coming to the event on
Saturday people like that no it's
amazing that you're starting coffee shop
because coffee coffee shops there's
actually research around this led to the
age of enlightenment boom look I mean
not even joking like yes there's
Empirical research that people people
come together in coffee houses and this
is like the breeding grounds of Korea
what we'll do is next we'll buy the
building next door and then we'll make
redkowski's burrito shop and then you
can get them a burrito the coffee for
your butt in the coffee for your mouth
sorry this is actually the reason real
quick okay the the second and third
floor of the building are our social
club so the second floor is going to be
a basic social hangout and the third
floor is going to be our members only
Social Club we're probably going to film
poker with the boys in this building on
the third floor where our top tier
members are able to actually hang out
the show is mostly just a table Talk
podcast meaning you get a handful of
people to hang out and I'll talk about
these issues and poker's a backdrop to
make it something more fun but then we
are going to have people come from all
over to hang out to meet each other to
share ideas and the goal is to build
community strengthen bonds between
people learn who our neighbors are share
our moral values and win a culture War
pierogies not tacos zooming out a little
bit and this is a conversation I've been
having in Britain with friends and and
like-minded people Eve the institutions
the corporations are all captured as we
believe they are by various ideologies
the response is that we need to build
our own Industries our own
infrastructure our own as you describe
uh businesses like this that are
widespread that is actually a great way
of defeating the ideological capture of
of uh so many Industries yep um I'm
really excited for the idea look if we
launch
uh franchises which I I expect we will
imagine this not only will we carry you
know our coffee brand but there's a
whole bunch of Jeremy's chocolate so uh
for our chocolate bars on the counter
for our impulse buys we'll get Jeremy
boring's uh you know chocolate brand if
we get a liquor license for upstairs
we'll have the conservative dads you
know uh Ultra right or whatever I have a
cigar business boom Winston cigars yeah
we're called 1573 which is the year that
tobacco first came to Britain might we
stock you yes yeah fantastic we'll we'll
have because especially if we're doing a
social club I don't know if we can
actually allow people to smoke in the
building you can get licenses we'll talk
later we'll talk about some cigars
because my man so uh when we were
talking about doing poker with the boys
obviously everyone asked can we smoke
cigars and I'm like I think the
challenge is like can you smoke indoors
and stuff but having a bunch of people
sitting around playing a game of poker
and smack talking and the the and I'll
stress this too the idea for the show
isn't actually about poker it's to have
a table with eight or nine people who
are all talking about various issues
with poker as kind of the through line
for everybody so you'll see some table
action and some some ribbing on each
other you have to be able to multitask
but it's good but you'll you'll get the
periodic you know like I was mentioning
that guy who mentioned was talking about
January 6th to meet the poker table that
stuff happens and these are really
interesting conversations when you get
random people who don't know each other
start talking about this stuff that'll
be fascinating but then you know they'll
light a cigar up we need to burn sticks
the problem you might have though is
that it's so ideologically in one way
that that you need to attract the people
who think differently how are we going
to do that it's a game of poker
but if you've got Crowder on the Telly
Oh you mean the coffee shops yeah this
is the point it's the Trojan Horse the
average person the Normie doesn't know
or care about Crowder and so they go to
their local shopping center where
they're picking up dog food and they're
like yeah I'm gonna grab a nice coffee
before I go home and then go uh oh
there's a coffee shop right there and
they walk in and they're like I'll do a
large iced coffee uh with you know half
and half and they're waiting and they
look over and there's the TV and they're
just watching and then they see Crowder
being like can you believe the Democrats
are doing this thing again and they're
just like huh how about that I don't
know businesses businesses have always
been solving problems that governments
have created so I I do understand the
business aspect here I'm working on a
vitamin business I'm working on a buck
coffee business I'm also trying to get a
pierogi beef liver business up and going
if anyone's in the Pierogi beef liver
industry hit me up uh please uh but uh
but I I do believe private Enterprises
can solve the problems that a lot of
governments do create regarding the Age
of Enlightenment the induction of coffee
into the Consciousness really did not
only stimulate but change the way people
communicated but it was also they
stopped drinking as much beer they
stopped drinking as much anheus or bush
products and started drinking coffee I'm
joking they just stopped drinking
alcohol as much it used to be because
the water was often contaminated they
would drink beer all day and it was just
a dark age but then yeah look into the
Steven Johnson research on coffee he's
he's the man on it coffee's great hey
we're gonna go to Super Chat so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com by
clicking join us at timcast.com and then
you'll get access to the members only
uncensored show which will be live at
about 10 10 p.m Eastern as soon as we
wrap the live show here we immediately
begin setting up the live show which
takes a few minutes then we go live
uncensored and if you've been a member
for at least six months or you sign up
at the 25 level you can actually call
into the show and ask us questions we
can only do a few per day we do about
three or four per day so not everybody
can get in but uh we try to take as many
as possible as often as possible I think
it's the most fun part of the day that
being said let's read your comments in
the super chats all right let's see we
got here let's uh get these super chats
and we'll start at the beginning
and where are we at
Jason by the way Tim this is really nice
Jason Corey says screw Bud Light and the
far left this Super Chat is a
celebration of buying my first
motorcycle that is being delivered
tomorrow Harley 2016 Roadster very cool
all right new in Kalamazoo news channel
says Tim Ian and the rest you have
inspired me to start my own local news
channel here on YouTube and just
uploaded my first video today here's
twenty dollars as a thank you let's
shout it out what's the name of the
channel new in Kalamazoo news channel
cool man no thank you thank you
congratulations
Jeremy dobler says nefarious movie opens
this weekend we need to support this
film yeah have you guys heard of uh of
this film nefarious no no
it's uh uh we was it was it Steve D is
that who who who oh my gosh Steve
prayers for Steve Dees he had an
infection a couple days ago his wife was
tweeting about itself but hopefully he's
doing good now uh also Steve's movie's
coming out that that was his movie right
I'm not I want to make sure I'm getting
this right what's the premise
it's a horror film let me make sure I
have this right I'm sure everyone in the
chat is already saying yes it's Steve D
Steve deese yeah nice work Steve I'm
pretty sure I'm correct on that one I
feel bad because we literally had him on
the show when he brought a screener and
I'm like make sure I'm not getting this
wrong
all right essay federally says Bill and
Ian's constant push for open source is
truly classically live uh liberal civil
libertarianism keep pushing spiral out
also Bill's idea of paying us all back
for AI training data instead of Ubi is
absolutely Godly yeah Bill suggests that
this is on Joe Rogan's podcast again
that in a form of Ubi that's paid
through the corporations that use your
data I thought it was genius
I mean rev share
pay creators let's do it I mean open
people should not it's very tempting to
use gpt4 but they should be paying
people if they're using your data
all right let's see we got John Hutto
says there are two sets of documents the
Discord are legit the telegram are
modified interesting is that is that
what they're saying that someone took
them and modified them
well if that's the case then maybe we
are incorrect and uh we'll have to
follow up on that one
all right narels chukowski says hey Tim
Charles hoskinson said he would come on
Tim castirally sent the invite let's
make that happen I kind of feel like we
invited him a long time ago who's he is
he the ethereum guy Nirvana
right right right right right yes uh
we'll uh we'll follow up on that one
all right where are we at Mr grizzly
bear says bomb threats have occurred at
most a b locations with screaming
matches between workers and managers
workers are walking out due to safety
concerns but we are told it's not
credible and to continue operations like
normal whoa what are you do you work at
Anheuser-Busch is that what you're
saying all you got to do is not buy the
product
Barney Boyle says did you see the Red
Bull hot air balloon skatepark no what
is that did they float a skate park into
the air and then skate on it I hope so
that sounds bad is that it is someone
want to Google that
sure sounds Red Bull all right Raymond g
Stanley Jr says Tim it goes like this
the more I learn about our government
the more I realize how dirty corrupt and
manipulative our US government is a
realization I wasn't wasn't expecting
from my Normie days Eyes Wide Open yeah
Red Bull put skate park 2 000 feet in
the sky
that's a floating skate park
floating skatepark news from 14 hours
ago oh I'll check that one out that
sounds pretty good and stuff cool
all right what do we got
let's see
David molinar uh what does it say Molin
narolo
says my God you will you guys will fall
for anything you really think Russia has
only lost 17 000 troops they lose that
much in less than a month I would just
say the exact same thing back to you do
you really think they lost 200 000
troops that's a huge amount of people
like we don't know we literally don't
know the us is going to say it's huge
Russia is going to say it's low pick
your pick your poison now I I doubt
either side is going to be factual on
this one
all right let's see OMG puppy says
Belling cat is associated with MI6
wow
a Siri designs as what does a 21 year
old have that security clearance that's
a good question good question yeah
all right what do we got here Lori
Dowell says Chris Martinson behind his
10 paywall showed the logistics
paperwork Tim should also find and post
Ukraine is within days of running out of
all kinds of equipment and necessary War
materials
I heard that but I also heard that the
uh the the
data was actually quite old so
so it may be a few months you know
different
all right let's see we got here
Aurora Isabella says love Ian's jacket
it looks so comfy Tim bought this for me
thank you very much we were at the mall
and I was like that looks like Ian and
you were right and then I was like I'm
going to buy manifest I want one so I'll
give you the comedy man yeah I got like
I'll get like a different color that's a
little bit more oh my gosh it's so cool
I mean I don't dry it either I just wash
it and hang it up to dry just keep it
fluffy Russell Hatton says Tim it's not
only a strategic marketing strategy it's
only a matter of time until people's
pronouns are Bud Light and identify as a
beer can
I think you're right actually
yeah we were talking earlier and someone
said like I wonder what dating is going
to be like like for my kids and I was
like
they're gonna go on a dating app and
they're going to meet a carrot and
they're going to meet in person and find
out to human and be like dude you told
me you were a carrot like you you carrot
fished me this is this is BS and it's a
joke but like what I mean to say is
online you can be anything and so people
are going to be like I'm a beer can or
like I'm a fish and then you're gonna
meet him it's like you're a person you
know what I mean like you lied and
they're gonna be like oh you don't tell
me that I identify my pronouns are beer
can
so there you go
Mitch the engineer says as someone
personally familiar with the dairy
explosion it was a freak accident caused
by automated Machinery with an
electrical short coupled with a methane
buildup during a slurry clean out of the
milking parlor wow wow
and even centralizing cows is dangerous
the same thing can happen with wheat and
wheat silos because there's like a gas
that builds up well that's the other
thing too like you see those bales of
hay those things burst into flames like
relatively often I guess what happens is
when they when they Bunch it all
together it starts breaking down inside
releasing flammable gases and then it
gets really really hot because it's
super packed and then it reaches
ignition and then when the whole thing
goes up correct yeah yeah they do this
thing I guess where they like stick a
crowbar or something inside it until you
aerate it yeah yeah and test the
temperature but sometimes they burn them
on purpose I don't know
yeah
all right David Mullen uh Molin arolo
says carbon dioxide makes up 0.04 of the
atmosphere up from 0.03 if it drops to
0.02 plant Life Starts dying off there
is no climate crisis period
methane I know is part of it too and
water vapor
yeah
super 503 dank says what's stopping them
from sending useless eaters to war
people like us I mean it's people like
you you know people that speak up
all right Kevin Corbett says fact jack
scheinerbach is not owned by a b inbev
was I wrong about that one I thought
that was on their website Let's uh
I'm gonna check real quick that's
important yeah
Anheuser-Busch products what do we have
here favorite beer while Tim's looking
that up Winston I'm sober I mean it's
still fun though I haven't touched beer
in a year and a half I think I had half
one a while ago I can't the cans there's
too much 12 16 ounces is too much I
think they should sell six ounces this
is my first beer in like six months and
I only want half yeah with no tolerance
half a beer is enough for me plus I'm
130 pounds is there anything that you
drink bro
come on is there anything that
Anheuser-Busch could do to redeem
themselves they could do an apology in
my opinion that gets more views than the
ad that caused the Uproar if they can do
that somehow they can create a viral
campaign of course it would be easy
they would just have to invert the whole
thing
and I don't know what do you mean I
don't know maybe just come out with a
can with something hilarious on it that
mocks the whole situation or or just go
at the other side find oh wow find a
figure on the others is a b finalizer
Cass Castle Corona Harbin hoe garden
Jupiter Lefty blonde Michelob Ultra
Modelo
skull Stella
maybe what if they put they should put
Blair white on the yeah or the Dalai
Lama that's what Luke that was what a
meme that he did earlier yeah put the
dolly um did you guys have you talked
about that yet
so for reference Dalai Lama was hanging
out with this kid there's a video of it
and he's forehead to forehead and then
he puts his tongue out and it's like
encouraging the kid to suck his tongue
it's so weird it is freakish and it
looked like a gorilla with another a
little monkey playing but it was still
very weird that's clearly what it is
it's pedophilia
there's no play rationalization there's
no silly there's no silly Sun sung and
that was talking that was the
rationalization was that he so he he
playfully yeah playfully oh I'm sorry I
said China back I might Shock Top
Shock Top not Shiner box Shock Top I
confuse that because they they share
letters apologies for that it's Shock
Top
all right you were correct Kevin Corbett
I apologize for that wanted to make sure
Tim really dug that one out that took
that's a journalistic Integrity right
there well I don't I mean if I'm wrong
I'm wrong E Smith says shinerbach is not
owned by Anne Bush thank God you are a
correct drinking one right now or
something he's like oh no they're
sitting there drinking it like no uh
Sparky says youngling beer is American
owned and brewed their golden pilsner is
First Rate its head guy was an early
adopter of anti-wokness
I mean I don't I my issue is like I
don't care if beer is is doing a pride
flag stuff I really don't care about
that I care that Dylan Mulvaney targets
children like I'm telling people like
could you imagine if they hired Mr Beast
and he comes out with a pack of Marlboro
Reds and he's like hey kids
light em up they're great I'd be like
what are you doing like no don't do that
so Dylan Mulvaney's audience is a bunch
of kids
they're promoting drinking alcohol to
kids among the other like ridiculous
stuff that don't move any does but like
it's more than just like you know Joe
Rogan came out and said oh who cares if
they're trying to get more people to
drink their beer why are you so mad
about it it's like yo I don't care that
Miller Coors did a pride flag thing they
I don't care that Yingling did a pride
flag thing I care that Del Mulvaney is a
deranged sociopath who mocks and insults
women and trans people and is trying to
sell beer to Children yes he's willing
to take money to influence young
children to destroy their liver and
brain like that's that that's that's
messed up this is another classic uh
trick that is played in in conversation
over the the trans issue is people go
why do you care it's only 0.01 of the
population no actually it's not it
affects all women so that's 50 of the
population you've got to protect women
if if people with penises I men are in
women's spaces women are not safe if you
have a mother or a sister or any female
friend I everyone it should be of your
concern and in my country we the state
we've been paying and our taxes have
been going to the state and has been as
has been revealed with the Tavistock
clinic and gids we state funded have
been giving kids irreversible sex uh
hormone uh uh sex hormone uh hormones
for the uh change to check to change sex
as well as puberty uh blockers this is a
serious issue that should worry everyone
it's total anyone who says why
do you care it's thing no it affects
everyone absolutely we'll talk more
about that in the member segment for
sure all right let's see we got here see
stallion says the end of the world is
just the beginning mapping the collapse
of globalization by Peter Zion gosh we
should have him on someday are you guys
familiar with Zion no I heard him
feelings about him I heard people be
very unhappy with them and other people
Rave and rant about him some stuff's
wrong but I like that he's got a killer
ponytail toy painter one says my
daughter son-in-law and grandkids cut
off all contact with us in June of 21
because we didn't get the jab there is
no uniting this country have faith no no
but I agree there's no unit in this
country I do think that there are people
who are initiated that don't know better
that you can probably talk to that's
that's true
but I think some of these people are
just
yeah I I like how do you stop people
from voting for a Democrat who is
attacking people in their cars you don't
there's just there's no way around that
give them a better option
well you got RFK running as a Democrat
you know or you can vote for Marion
Williamson and I mean that sincerely
Marin Williamson is is loads better than
uh Biden or anyone else the Democrats
have to offer and that's why they
attacked her so ruthlessly this poor
woman you know she's like she's this
this lovey-dovey like self-help person
conscious she's into Consciousness and
then they started calling her the
woo-woo Crystal lady and she's like why
are they insulting me and I'm like oh
you poor naive you know summer summer
spirit just yeah you didn't understand
how evil and corrupt these people are
when it comes to power and she genuinely
thought she probably thought entering
the race that you know the media was was
real and journalists were honest and
then all of a sudden they started just
ripping her to shreds
feel bad and then she had that moment
where I think she was on Tucker Carlson
or something like that where she said
the right is so much nicer and the left
is so mean and nasty and then she had to
come up and be like no no I don't mean
it
so anyway look I would vote for a
Democrat that's that's reality I don't
care who it is but
you know that is true they need you you
need subversion and Alternatives would
you vote for Democrat if it was Tulsi
gabbard
I don't know probably not
um I supported her when she was running
last time in the primaries you know and
then she didn't win obviously but um
there's a bunch of things I disagree
with Iran but she's come around a lot of
things as well and I think she is pretty
good the issue at this point is voting
for a Democrat empowers the malignancy
within the Democratic party so if she
was an independent you would be more
likely to yeah the issue is I'm not
going to give a vote to the Democratic
party it doesn't matter who's in charge
you've got two too many I would say
99.9 of the democratic party is as
corrupt as corrupt can be I can say like
maybe rokana is okay but he's still kind
of bad
and so that's the that's the best the
Democratic party has to offer the
Republicans like 87 bad so that that's
like the the only reason I consider
voting Republican is because you have a
new Insurgent party you know Maga that's
been taking over and the freedom caucus
has actually gained substantial power in
Congress
so I think it's worth it
all right what do we got
Bree Sullivan says can you talk about
the restrict act it's not getting talked
about enough and it goes Way Beyond
Banning Tick Tock it it'll control what
you can post on social media
yeah it basically it doesn't even name
Tick Tock they give the Commerce
Department in the Secretary of Commerce
authority to just pick which apps get
banned and you know there's fines for
using vpns it is it's basically like
they they manipulated everyone into
saying oh yeah we have to ban Tick Tock
they're giving data to the to the
Chinese and then they bring in this like
Patriot Act 2.0 type situation which is
it they manipulated people on Tick Tock
so like don't I mean I think if the
cat's out of the bag that everyone who
was concerned about Tick Tock knows not
to support the restrict act at this
point but what do you think about the
tactic 2 force uh Tick Tock to free its
software code to agpl3 in order to exist
in the United States
I mean yeah I don't I don't know about
forcing
it was actually proposed by members of
Congress that they will have to release
their code and how their algorithm
functions and and how their data
collection functions if they want to
persist in the United States and I think
that's a solution because if they if
they then and they said oh we'll get
back to you on that if we can then see
that they are actively trying to
manipulate Us and how they're doing it
okay that actually gives us more of in
our Arsenal to ban them or shut them
down or legislate how they should be
acting and then if it's true there are
stealing data and giving it to China
which we we're pretty sure like we know
they're doing it then we will see that
before we just say you know what we've
heard these stories so you're out we say
okay here's your chance to prove you're
not as bad as they said you are Tick
Tock said no they were just like uh
we'll we'll let you know so that's why
I'm kind of like Bantam it's we it's bad
enough our social media is manipulative
and evil I don't want China in here
doing that stuff but the thing is the
Google and Facebook we don't know that
just because they're us-based they could
just as easily be sharing data with
China
spy club they're all sharing date with
each other and so I think if we if we
legislated that Tick Tock had to do it
and free their software court that that
would be that would be a sort of
precedent to then Force Google and
Facebook to free their software code and
because they're functioning in the
Commons I you just can't I don't think
specifically say only Tick Tock has to
share their code there would have to be
something more Universal foreign social
networks that have over 100 million
users per month or something
I mean yeah it would be I don't know I
think it could be surgical Tick Tock is
a foreign owned corporation that we have
concerns they're stealing data and
manipulating people in this country
propagandistic efforts so we so isolate
specifically so they they open it and
then we see that it's just super
invasive and then then we have hard
justification to escalate but if they
release it and say
okay we're willing to change these
things and then we can actually be like
you have to stop
this this part of the code is bad this
part of the code is bad and this part of
the code is bad get rid of those and you
can keep operating
the app cannot function without
surveillance the other option is we
could take the code and build our
Americans yeah build the America I just
feel like the regulation would be better
to do like an encrypt act and get
everybody intend encrypted and also make
the App Store much better labeled for
the problem though is that I don't care
about data like if you're concerned
about your privacy stop using these
things the problem is the algorithmic
manipulation the problem is that if you
we're banned from Tick Tock so okay so
we're biased to a certain degree we
broke no rules what rules like does this
show break we don't get banned from
YouTube We Don't Break The Rules we're
very you know on the level Tick Tock
banned us
probably because the conversation we
conversations we have they don't want
young people seeing they want young
people to get a psychotic message that
breaks their brains so I'm just like
Tick Tock is bad get rid of it it's just
not gonna stop it it's gonna enrage
everybody and they're gonna you're gonna
Empower all the you're gonna Empower all
the pro Tick Tock people to think that
they're being rebellious by using a VPN
and going in using Tick Tock anyway go
for it well I think good luck getting a
VPN and downloading the APK onto your
Android phone because you can't get an
iPhone anymore unless you jailbreak it I
don't I I don't care I don't say this
here's a simple solution Rumble launch a
mobile app that has shorts
Rumble I I I got I got pro skateboarders
heading out this is huge that rumble's
gonna be doing Pro skateboarding
I was I was surprised to hear they're
doing they're doing the RNC they're
doing gaming and they're doing Pro
skateboarding I think rumble's on track
to win he's like Chris pavlovski watches
the show sounds like so he's got him and
the team know exactly what needs to
happen to win a culture War and the one
thing I've talked about is that Rumble
is too much of an echo chamber the first
thing Rumble did was they went after
those who were censored to build base
now they're targeting general interest
which is the smartest thing they can be
doing and I also add all of our
infrastructure is with Rumble our
website our after show and all that
stuff we're just I don't guess I guess
Legacy on YouTube for the time being
have you guys with Minds been
investigating doing shorts
yeah vertical video is essential yeah we
we have like a swipe feed story type
vertical video feed on our mobile app
and yeah kind of getting going deeper
into that is is huge
oh here we go Todd B says Tim did you
see Stephen King's tweet about if men
could get pregnant they were there uh
there would be backing for abortion you
can guess the response but I will let it
be a surprise I did see that and
everyone called him a bigot and they
were like how dare you transphobe Etc
well you're welcome on the show Stephen
yeah good luck
Brian forsaken as the world crumbles
says Kyle Rittenhouse bud can
yep
all right normies get out says the
brewery is owned by the gambrinous
company a family-owned company based in
San Antonio which also owns
trumer Brewery in Berkeley California
Shiner is not owned by Anheuser-Busch I
want to make sure I stress that one
because I meant Shock Top not shinerbach
you know is the Shah sound that you know
or the awesome that's what got me they
got me I was wrong I made a mistake made
a mistake guys don't uh
don't don't be mad all right Nathan
Sherwood says Luke doesn't need alcohol
because his brain has clearly already
been destroyed
slam that's a good one
I can't remember what happened but we
were watching a movie or something I
think I think it was when we were
watching I heard what it was but
everyone in the room like some someone I
think someone made a joke or I did and
then Luke and Mia's laughing and
everyone else goes oh and I thought that
was hilarious that like you know me and
Luca have a similar sense of humor where
it can be like
offensive and raunchy and he just laughs
the more offensive the more funnier it
is let's just be honest and uh yeah I
might have brain damage probably true
from all that tear gas too much red pill
let's see
uh let's see H Unstoppable says Decker
Carlson was on a podcast and from what
he said these objects or beings most
likely have been here a long time and
they seem to be going in and out of
water at high speeds we don't see them
in space as much as out of water
William Cooper was also documenting that
uh many many years ago in his book
Behold The Pale Horse describing objects
that he saw as the naval intelligence
officer literally coming out of water
like it was not breaking any kind of
force field at all and moving extremely
fast as underwater as it did in the sky
so he was describing these things for a
very long time and we have seen very
similar reports from a lot of different
individuals they're not they're not
aliens they're admins
and they are moving as fast as they can
because they have no clipping turned on
which means they are not interacting
with matter they're moving just through
it have you seen ball Lightnings no they
actually it's like it's real it's crazy
lightning that moves through matter or
through windows and stuff what if we're
in a simulation and what we think are
aliens are literally just like yeah
they're admins yeah they're going around
they're like correcting errors and
they're like dealing with user problems
and then the issue is a lot of people
are like yeah so the people obviously
are going to say like I don't get any
help from the admins yeah because we're
all NPCs like we are in the program as
non-player characters and right now
there's like you know maybe maybe 50 000
players or a few million players in a
world of billions and they contact the
admins for assistance you know and
they're listening to shows like this
like when you play Fallout 3 and you got
three dog and he's like on the radio in
the post-apocalyptia I wonder if there's
only a certain amount of bandwidth to
have a certain amount of PCS at once
because some days I feel like an NPC and
I'll be like what did I just do the last
four hours see Ian you exist to
facilitate a video game for other people
we're all just NPCs we're just we're
just you know
we are named NPCs like we're not like
shopkeeper you know or like you know
mechanic it's like we're NPCs with names
so it's not much of an upgrade from a
regular NPC we're all still NPCs but you
know that's the simulation all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
if you like it and become a member at
timcast.com go to timcast.com click join
us because we're gonna have an
uncensored show live on the front page
of the website in about 10 minutes and
you don't want to miss it we got a lot
to talk about you can follow the show at
timcastirl on Instagram you can follow
me personally everywhere at timcast
Winston you want to shout anything out
yeah you can follow me at Mr
windmarshall on Twitter or at Winston
Marshall on Instagram and I've got a
podcast martial matters which you can
find all the usual podcasts outlets and
YouTube
right on Bill what's up guys thanks for
having me you can find me at minds.com m
i n d s.com or on the App Stores search
minds and uh yeah also we're opening
we're reopening our Equity crowdfunding
so if you want to own stock be a part of
it wefinder.com minds and this Saturday
this Saturday my I guess mine's fests
we're going to be streaming live
um on Destiny's Channel and having crazy
and and on minds.com we're actually
launching our first live streaming test
nice I mean yeah I'll say this too like
if you do want to go you probably should
buy your tickets now because when we go
live tomorrow our timcast IRL is sold
out I guarantee you the moment we say
tomorrow is mines the people who are
already there are gonna buy whatever's
left it's
tickets.vulcanpresents.com I'm gonna be
there Ian's gonna be there thank you
guys so much for bringing it all
together it really means a lot I want to
shout out a person that said that I
should call my enema coffee business but
light uh that might be a real thing so
thank you my website is
lucanfiltered.com the members Meetup
today was awesome I'm going to be doing
another one in a few days in Miami Lucan
lucanfilter.com and soon I'm gonna have
a very big challenge ahead of me I'm
going to be confronting a very very bad
person The Potato Man himself Sheamus
Coughlin I have agreed to his terms
there will be a debate and very strong
intellectual fights that will happen
between me and the Potato Man next week
on we are change on YouTube it's going
to be a big one it's going to be crazy
and I wanted to shout out I'm Ian
Crossland if you don't know uh someone
that I met today at Luke's Gathering
that has a uh the cross state uh
situation with his daughter similar to
The Jeff younger case I think I don't
know a lot about it but I wanted to
point you guys to uh website
www.rescue Becks it's rescue beex.com
he's asked for support and just to bring
some awareness to this situation so
hopefully this will help I had a great
time today you guys everyone that was at
the Gathering and Luke again thank you
for inviting me Winston Bill love you
love you dudes Tim great thanks Tim
right on him of course sir just pressing
the buttons yeah what's up guys I'm uh
sergio.com on Twitter come argue with me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
in about 10 minutes thanks for hanging
out